to the youtube channel and to any
podcast app um for me i i love this
episode i mean the thing i look for on
any tv show or when i'm interacting with
any story is to feel something and i
felt a lot this episode uh before we
turned on the mics we were talking about
the cold open and in this case that
opening to the episode was so unsettling
and did such a good job of signaling
you're going to see something important
and kind of set a sort of foreboding
tone so you feel tense the entire
episode
and
when you see nacho grab that glass you
feel even more tense because you think
is there some way out of this it's hard
to imagine there is because we know that
everybody in the scene besides nacho has
to survive to breaking bad but somehow
you hope there's a way out
and
the twist ends up being that yes nacho
does die
but not in exactly the way you'd expect
and it ends up being a sort of uh almost
a heroic moment where for the first time
in three or four seasons he finally has
an act of agency where he gets to make a
choice so it was a very tense episode
but an oddly hopeful one in that sense
and i think that's perfectly captured by
that image of the bright blue flower in
the midst of a storm and uh just one
more thought to add to this which is
given there's still 10 episodes left in
the
series for something with so much
finality to happen to a main character
uh
this plot line is far from over i think
we're going to see a lot of fallout yet
to come and with every closed door
there's a lot more doors that open and
so there's a there's still a big mystery
hanging here and a lot more excitement i
think waiting for us
cool jim you want to you want to go next
yeah absolutely i'm jim one half bald
move as pete said uh we are primarily
podcasters uh over at bald move so you
find our better casts all on uh you know
itunes spotify all those normal places
uh i thought
also that this episode is excellent um
it's hard to argue with the drama that
they pull
uh from from something that feels so
inevitable right it's it's it's
interesting to me that like i kept
looking for the switcheroo like you gill
and adam i i kept thinking like okay how
is he gonna get out of this because he's
nacho he's my guy he's got to get out of
this
but
it also feels inevitable that he can't
get out of it and that's just
the switcheroo is it goes exactly how
you kind of think it has to go and and
you see so many other television shows
doing the switcheroo and maybe pulling
something a little less
convincing uh here to to get him out of
the situation continue the drama i just
love that it doesn't happen that way
that it it goes exactly how you expect
and at the same time that somehow
surprises you well you know this is the
right way to subvert expectations i
think the uh the double d's could take a
note on from them
[Music]
absolutely
yeah i i think the the one that is one
of the things that that really makes it
matter is the inevitability of it um
i think nacho gets to that place and
we'll talk about this in a bit but he
gets to that place long before we do as
viewers you know he he understands
what his reality is
and we don't want to
and and they just they just sort of tug
on that the whole way through all the
way into the last moments and
i think that um
you know it
i i don't want to just
to just briefly you know touch on it it
they also did a pretty good job of
balancing things because this really is
his his
his episode you know this is the nacho
episode
he's the guy
who's had himself in the between the
rock and a hard place for as long as we
can remember at this point
and um it's it's it's it's it was
surprising that it was an episode three
but i think it almost had to be
at the same time because of the fact
that
it's just so
final
that they you know they had to structure
it in a way that they could keep a
little bit of the other story going but
just sort of just sort of be here and
and just sort of
just let it
take over this part of the season so
yeah i think it was uh
um you know i i
i wasn't expecting it were you got did
you guys think that this might happen in
this episode going in
uh personally i so i was i was mildly
kind of spoiled because a recap of the
episode got leaked early and i didn't
see the recap but it happened to pop up
in google search results and i saw the
headline was there are good deaths and
bad deaths and so i went in thinking hmm
that's that's an interesting headline
there and then once i saw the cold open
and just how intense it was
i started to suspect it might but i
still wasn't totally sure i think until
he made the phone call to his father
which thankfully happens pretty early in
the episode at that point that felt like
such a good buy call that i thought it
really feels like that's what we're
heading towards
yeah what about you jim
the moment i i understood what was
happening and that we weren't going to
get the
last ditch effort to get him out of this
is when mike gives him the nod when he
they're in the desert that he's getting
out of the van and mike just nods to him
to go off to get into his sniper's nest
that's the type of nod that mike gives
you when he knows he's never going to
see you again
and yeah that really tipped me off and
from there i was like oh no this is this
is going to go bad
that's kind of like the that's that's
sort of the nod you hope to earn from
mike but never actually hope to be on
the receiving road
yeah yeah you're working towards that
but never actually want to see it yeah
that's a great way to think about it
though one thing about that nod i
noticed re-watching is that nacho's the
one who initiates the nod and i thought
that was in keeping with the rest of the
episode where it seems like nacho's very
at peace with what with what's going to
happen and mike is the one who's
struggling a little more with it you
know when it's time for mike to beat up
nacho because he's a little too pretty
nacho's ready for it and mike says first
things first he pours a couple of drinks
so i think some of that nod from nacho
was of course it was goodbye but it was
also like don't worry i'm cool with what
is going to happen like do not carry the
burden of this you know this is on me
yeah and and so i i like i said in the
beginning i wanted to talk about a few
other points that happened here before
we just go full nacho
so let's pull back for a second and
um
i think that a couple of things
i think mostly like i said it was it was
primarily all about nacho but i thought
there were some two really interesting
points over there on
the um jimmy and kim side of things and
the first was 88 eriksen and the fact
that she found out about the guzman's
real identity
and how she goes to kim because she
thinks she's the more reasonable of the
two
and i really liked how whenever she was
talking about jimmy they're talking
about saul i guess in this case you know
she laid it out that she thought he was
you know beyond all the showmanship
beyond all the other stuff he really was
a lawyer and a human being and he wanted
to do the right thing and you know that
is the perfect description of this
character jimmy mcgill
and you know i i i really love that on
the first watch but then i was thinking
as it after the fact
she's talking to kim
kim knows jimmy more than anybody else
so kim is having this exact same
realization that we are whenever she's
listening to this she's like yeah that
is jimmy but then she also makes the
choice to
steer him away from doing the right
thing you know at least from their point
of view the you know the the district
the uh court's um point of view
so i i thought that um
you know i i figured that
this lalo situation was going to come
back in one way or another
but it seems like everything's pretty
much set up on on two sides and i liked
at when i thought about it some more i
liked how there's sort of this
she whenever she talks to jimmy about
this she brings it down to a binary
right that's just you can be a friend of
the cartel or you can be a rat and that
may be you know a really smart way to
look at it
but
it doesn't really give them an out you
know what i mean like nobody chooses to
be a rat and
i thought about how there there's a real
parallel in in what's going on with with
nacho
which these two characters seem totally
disconnected because
he he he he realized that he had a
binary he could run and maybe have his
father pay the price for that
or he could could sacrifice himself
and i thought it was interesting how
they're doing that you know they
they have
the characters stories are our
collection of choices that they make and
that's what makes them you know so
relatable and good
and it's interesting to see how they're
getting
those choices are getting smaller and
they get down to these binaries where
there's nothing else there so
you know what did you guys point
oh sorry uh yeah
kim is sort of forcing saul goodman into
this binary situation because if you
look at his history he's he's kind of
all about dancing over around the line
and skirting the rules and and and
uh kind of operating in all these
different morally gray areas like just
the first example i could think of was
when he went all out of his way to to
do this scheme at the the kind of old
folks home to help that that woman
become friends with her group again
after he kind of tore them apart and
it's like he didn't have any kind of
financial illegal incentive to do it he
did it because he felt bad because he
had this kind of conscience
um meanwhile he's also committing all
kinds of scams and and these things so
he he he kind of lives in this really
complicated gray area and and now you
have kim giving him this sort of binary
option and and i have a feeling he's
going to
find some kind of strange middle ground
that we that's sort of unpredictable
here
it's interesting because you know it's
it's rock and hard place right it's the
name of this episode and i definitely
felt that
uh in in the gym jimmy and kim stuff
when she's giving him you know you can
either be a friend of the cartel you can
be a rat and
we all know what happens to rats right
it's it's not really a choice like you
said uh
and then you've got
the other side of this which is lalo who
has a choice to save himself potentially
or save his father again i think that's
not a choice for him everything we've
seen from him
you know tells us that he's gonna choose
his father every time
uh so yeah i think like
i do expect that jimmy will have
something up his sleeve um he always
does it but
if if you look at him where he ends up
in breaking bad
how how much do we know about him right
like that's the thing that's interesting
to me because the options are still open
even though we have a future with this
character i feel like the options are
still pretty open he
knows who lalo is but of course he does
he's already met lalo right um
in in this show so
you know he could be still affiliated
with the cartel he could maybe not be uh
so i so i don't feel like he's in quite
as much of a hard place as
nacho was but yeah yeah there's
definitely
a binary choice to be made here but he's
not a binary kind of guy
yeah i think um
you know a couple of interesting things
i want to react to that you said um
first uh ericsson when she says that
saul goodman you know underneath the
showmanship and everything he's really a
good person
uh it's your point jim i think we don't
really know where saul is at when we get
to breaking bad we only saw a small
slice of his life and it's really
interesting how i can't think of many
other shows where the big looming
mystery of the show is what is inside
this character's brain later on we saw
saul goodman in breaking bad but if you
scratch under the surface is he a good
person maybe he is now but is that still
true when you fast forward
you know four years when he meets walter
white
and then also thinking about the the
parallels p between jimmy and nacho this
episode
uh i think back in season five mike sort
of laid out one of the primary themes of
the show we all make choices it puts us
on as jimmy put it bad choice road so
for me a lot of the show is about
what are the things that put you on that
road what happens as you move further
along on that road and i think part of
nacho's thematic role on the show is
kind of giving us a glimpse
further along on that road he made some
bad choices and eventually it brought
him to a point where he lost all control
and like like you alluded to
the choices become smaller and smaller
and it got to a point where he had to
sacrifice himself i don't think jimmy's
quite at that point yet but we do start
to see the choices narrow and what waits
for him at the end of bad choice road
we've of course seen glimpses of it but
there is still that mystery of it
it involves a cinnabon that's right
yeah and um
i'm really curious to see how that that
develops there and
you know it ties into the other thing i
wanted to talk about which was
hule another guy who knows jimmy pretty
well by this point
he was just he just couldn't understand
why they were doing what they were doing
they have a legitimate jobs you know
they have legit money coming in
they really don't have that really does
how could that make sense to anybody who
was not in it you know what i mean um
so i really like that part as well
because
you got nacho he's in the life or death
situation very literally um
just tortured every step of the way
and then you have these two on the other
side and it looks kind of ridiculous in
comparison
and you know
the point i guess you know the the idea
still is that
kim wants to do this thing
you know that is a good thing she wants
to set up this pro bono practice
but it you know
they're starting to get into the to the
region of like what you're doing doesn't
really make sense anymore for what
you're trying to accomplish
so
i don't know it i mean obviously it's
going to take off in this next couple of
episodes but
i thought that was a nice a nice note
that they touched on there that hey look
at that you know look at these people
what they're doing and having heel do it
i thought was a really good choice
yeah there were a couple of moments in
this episode where i felt like a
character was kind of speaking for me so
the other example would be
nacho when he was yelling at the
salamancas and telling them how horrible
they are because when you're watching
that scene you have the realization
everybody in this scene is dead by the
end of breaking bad why are you all such
horrible people and so nacho just lays
all that out
similar moment here where i want to
shake jimmy and say what are you doing
uh you know you're with kim this great
person well in certain respects
you know you you could have a great
career you're a great lawyer why are you
doing this and huel ends up saying
exactly that and i'm so curious when
these characters get asked those
questions i'm always so curious what are
they going to say and in this case i
think jimmy was sort of parroting kim
a little bit self-justifying but when
huel leaves the car the look on jimmy's
face is not one of confidence to me he
seems
pretty unsure of himself he doesn't
really yeah right there that is not the
face of a confident happy person well
you know and that's why it's ironic that
the ada goes to talk to kim about this
because the person she'd have better
luck getting through to in this moment
in time is probably jimmy but how could
she know that right knowing everything
she knows about saga yeah yeah yeah yeah
true that's why it's fantastic though
you know yep
yeah i i i when i was making the video
for this that's the part that that kept
coming i kept coming back to uh you know
the part i kept coming back to as well
was that
jimmy is certainly he he's saying he's
got his talking points ready but he's
he's just as much trying to convince
himself as he is he'll i mean
it's not he can't sell it and that's
what jimmy does he sells it you know
you know there's almost uh somewhat of a
parallel and this is a thought i'm just
having now so it's it's gonna take some
more time to think about but there's a
bit of a parallel between gus and mike
and kim and jimmy in terms of this
alliance forming between two people who
over time you start to see the many ways
in which their moral compasses and goals
sort of diverge from each other
yeah so just a little seed to plant
there
yeah and um the other thing i think on
the non nacho front i guess would be
the fact that we haven't seen lalo for a
couple of episodes in a row do you guys
have any thoughts about that
i mean i miss him puzzle
yeah for sure
that's the biggest puzzle to me of all
this is what is he doing south of the
border what kind of proof can he gather
over there
uh and maybe you guys talked about this
a little bit last time i got about
halfway through your last stream uh
before we had to do this one but
yeah i
i'm looking forward to finding out more
about what he's doing still south of the
border that could lead back to gus
yeah i i guess i got sort of what sorry
about that i got sort of poisoned on
this a little bit because peter gold
said something in an interview that just
it it was so specific that i can't i
can't really shake it and think about
anything else so
i'm just gonna sit out and let you guys
talk about it you know if i if i were
the cartel i would not trust peter gould
with uh orvin skilligan with much
information because they they seem to
just be letting everything slip
yeah he he it i mean i
yeah i don't wanna i don't really even
wanna talk about it because like i said
it just sort of the way that it
the way that he the way that he
introduced this in the interview it just
it has to be what he's doing and it's
pretty far
away from from the normal
thought process i would say you know
what i mean i i don't know if we
mentioned it last week or not but
um
i can't really even
weigh in on where lalo is because that's
all i can think about man all i can say
is it's the way you're describing it has
me so intrigued to finally see how it
plays out
yeah it's a it's a it's a little left
field but it could be wrong i might be
reading too much into it as well
if there's nothing else to say if
there's nothing else you want to add
about lalo then we can talk about the
man of the hour
michael mando giving us a world-class
performance
that telephone call which we'll get to
in a bit i mean that just that was just
some some great
acting there and a great story
a great episode the way it was put
together and i wanted to talk about i
wanted to start right from the beginning
that opening teaser because
it really hit me when i was watching
this like how trained of a of a you know
a viewer of these you know of breaking
bad and better call saul i have become
over this time you know
like it just the way that it opened
i knew that this was going to be
one for the ages you know something was
going to happen this was going to be you
know nothing was going to be the same
after this episode
the piece of glass
you know that that idea sticks in your
head and
you know the whole time i'm just looking
for where that's going to come in during
the episode what did you guys think
about this opening teaser
well i just thought it was i mean it was
very kind of it's a sort of as poetic as
you can get using visuals and even one
thing we kind of haven't touched on
through our coverage of this over the
week was everything leading up to the
flower and the glass and the rain you
see all these twisted roots and and it's
kind of all gnarled and weird looking
and you have the sound of like
rattlesnakes or something that at least
reminds you of that um so it just kind
of adds to this notion of of nacho is
kind of a guy surrounded by
sort of allegorical snakes and he was
kind of in in this horrible situation
and in the end there's some kind of
beauty or some kind of
honor that kind of grew out of it that
that's one way i've been looking at it
and i just want to add just how unusual
an opening it is for a tv series or for
a show where just to open with a you
know couple minute long
silent except for the sounds in the
world there's no characters and it's
essentially just visual poetry for a
couple of minutes
but of course it's all organic it all
makes sense to the story
but it essentially was a visual poem
that kind of just gives you this
metaphorical landmark to remember when
you think back on nacho
and you know when you see what actually
happens to him how he takes his own life
you think back to this image
and
it just gives you a very impactful
powerful thing to remember when you
think back on the character
here's the thing about that intro for me
uh because i am very much one of those
trained uh viewers that you're talking
about uh i i see an opening like that
i'm thinking okay
there's this piece of glass it's gonna
be significant throughout the episode
where are they going to use it and when
we got to the end and nacho uses it
i felt
i felt let down but here's why i missed
a single shot in the episode that tells
you
where that glass is from and why it's
important
the the shot of nacho seeing the
reflection of himself in the trash can
i missed that shot
and so it didn't quite make nearly as
much sense and then we got a flood of
emails after we did our podcast
people just saying like
it's it was in the trash he saw himself
it and it makes total sense now that i
think about it uh so
it's interesting that better call saul
does that right they they will have
extreme patience to show you a scene
like this cold open uh that doesn't make
any sense in context until the end of
the episode
uh and then they will also
put something that's very subtle that
you could miss pretty easily in the
episode if you're not paying close
attention and if you don't remember
previous episodes
uh in there and just kind of expect you
to roll with it i'm i'm
when you miss it it's a real bummer but
when you catch it it feels super
rewarding
uh publicly discussing a show while
you're watching it especially a show
like breaking a better call saul will
very harshly teach you the lesson that
you really need to pay attention to
details because i was getting flashbacks
as soon as you said you missed something
and got a flood of emails i know how
that feels people get
people get really riled up
oh yeah yeah
yeah i um
i i i didn't i didn't miss that but i
have had similar experiences where
there's just one thing and and it can
throw off the whole
the whole thing that they're going for i
i thought here
um i definitely saw a lot of questions
about you know did mike give him the
glass or did you know where did he get
you know where did he get the idea for
the glass or was that part of some plan
and yeah it's it's a little bit subtle
um i i mean i saw what was going on the
first time whenever we went through
there
but i didn't really it didn't all really
fall into place until
until like the he actually you know
pulls it out at the end
and um
i really thought that you know what you
were saying um
i think it was yeah adam was saying that
it was how that that
the way that the camera moved in the
beginning in retrospect it looks it is
sort of like the journey
that you know that he went on and um man
that
sometimes when i think about the you
know when i think about this in in a
vacuum you know just as an individual
piece it's kind of hard to imagine that
how they're going to top some of these
things you know what i mean but i but i
fully expect them to
at the same time
uh i i just wanted to real quick thank
uh jim watari for the 199 and he says
that lalo is in the cartel severance
program
and i would yeah that would be a great
crossover if uh after bcs is over
if we had lalo show up in the basement
floor over at lumen
i mean you definitely do see two sides
to lalo you see the all smiles cooking a
great meal in the back of a restaurant
to the i will coldly murder
a very lovely couple or a
22 year old working at a travel wire
so hey that could be a way to cope
yeah it might be his audi that does all
the killing
[Laughter]
so
um you know i guess from the from the
teaser we can move on to
the the getaway and um
you know the the in the actual episode
we pick up with him right after he gets
away from
the cousins and we kind of knew that he
wasn't going to get very far in that
truck they didn't even really break a
sweat to try to do anything other than
shoot out one of the tires and um
i really
this the whole the visuals in the tanker
that really that really hit me whenever
i was watching the first time because
you know it's his life you know he can't
get away from it like that is the whole
point right he can't walk away if he
would have been able to walk away he
would have done it a long time ago and
and just seeing him like submerge
himself and be covered with this sludge
that you know that you can go take a
shower you can go do whatever you want
but you just can't get that all off of
you you know what i mean it just stays
on you it's in the fiber of everything
that you got going on there and um
i heard michael mando say some things
about it and he said he thought about
that as the point where
it was his point of no return you know
he sort of died and was re reborn there
and was on his path
from that point forward
um
i think it you know for me it was the
point where i was like okay they're not
going to just do this for
three or four more episodes like
something's gonna happen in this story
soon because you know
the reality of what we were talking
about last week when we were talking
about it he doesn't really have any
options
he doesn't really have any leverage
this is where it really started to hit
me that you know we were in the
countdown towards the end
what are you doing
once he made the decision to hide in the
sludge of the oil the first thing i
thought of was the scene in schindler's
list where the kids decide to hide like
in the
in all the waste and like the latrine to
to avoid being detected
i don't know if there was any kind of
intentional
or at least if it was in the writers
minds as they were coming up with this
like oh you know it's kind of like that
scene
but just this just this idea of of doing
anything you possibly can to survive uh
really hits hard especially when you
consider
all this did was buy him and not all
this did but it bought him more time
and it helped him escape uh
torture essentially um
but it but it's like he he's he's not
even really doing this because he's
gonna get to live or survive or get the
ending he wants he's just
trying to make the the absolute optimal
outcome of a just an abs a horrible
situation
mm-hmm
yeah obviously oh sorry go ahead
oh it's okay uh yeah i said this on uh
our podcast i'm i'm constantly impressed
with this show
and breaking bad was like this too where
they will take characters to depths that
you never expected them to go to
uh links that that are surprising uh
every time you see them and
it's always because
another character is willing to go
somewhere you thought they wouldn't go
you know and this is like a reaction
because nacho gets in the the tanker he
thinks
okay i'll just hide in here but we know
the cousins the cousins are relentless
right they're going to come after him
they're going to check every square inch
and that shot is just like when he goes
into the oil here yeah it's so amazing
because it they stayed with him and they
talked about this on the insider cast
how he had to hold his breath for like a
minute under this stuff
uh
and it goes under we watch that we watch
the pool settle and the entire time you
can hear the cousin walking up the
ladder
and across the top of the tanker and you
just realize
he had to do this like no no sane human
being would ever do this but he had to
otherwise
this other relentless force was coming
after him
yeah that's a great point these shows do
such a good job exploring the chain
reaction of decisions uh even with
something like
walter white
allowing jane to die in front of him
leading to this this plane crash over
albuquerque like
no you know few decisions no matter how
trivial go kind of unaddressed and
unpunished
do you have anything you want to add to
the tanker situation gail
uh no i'll just say that
obviously a very tense scene i feel like
any time a character has to hold their
breath for a certain period of time it's
always a very suspenseful situation but
here as always the writers have better
call saul find a way to up the ante he's
not holding his breath underwater like
tom cruise in mission impossible he is
in a shallow oil puddle
and then one bubble yeah exactly
so super intense
and then this episode does such a good
job of making this a very visual journey
for nacho and we'll talk about more of
that when we get into the next couple of
scenes but here he's sort of literally
dragged through the mud you know it's
oil it's not mud but
this is almost the lowest point of his
journey
and they find a way to show it to us
very visually
yeah
i mean it's just it's just disgusting
thinking about being covered with oil
the smell of it i mean just everything
about it is is uncomfortable
and uh you know yeah give it you have to
give
michael mando credit for that i mean he
he sounded like he eagerly
jumped in that that
in the uh in the in the process of
making that and um he you know he really
he really made the made the scene for
sure
so the next thing that we have to get to
i guess is this phone call and
there's a couple of things about this um
when i watched it i looked at this as
him
more of a just about of a release of
just letting go like i just want to hear
my dad one more time
and then i'll be i'll be okay to do what
what comes next and
um
you know i thought
that i thought that this was more that
that's really what that was really my my
you know it was so emotional he's he
sells it so well
that that's really as far as i as i as i
went with it and you know what what it
made me think about was you know nacho
is this kind of character who
there's all these different kinds of
characters in these worlds but in this
world but you know he's the kind that
you can actually
one of the few when you think about it
that you can actually root for him based
on his
decisions you know not who he was or or
who he's trying to be but
he does literally try to do the right
thing whenever he has an opportunity to
do that and and this sort of you know
this sort of brought that up because
in my mind he's doing this he's just
trying to act as normal as he can
because he doesn't want his father to
know how bad it really is like he's
trying to protect him
he wants this thing he you know he wants
this this one one connection but
he's not willing to
you know
he's not really he's not willing to like
take him to that same place with him you
know what i mean like he wants to keep
his father as safe as he can be in that
situation
and so i was surprised a little bit
whenever i heard michael mando say that
there was a subtext here of like
hey dad you know you can you can we can
still run you know like that that he
thought that that was going on between
them and i don't i don't know if it was
written that way or if that was just how
he he you know prepared for the scene or
whatever
but um
you know i man the scene it really hit
me hard whenever i watched it the first
time
yeah as i say i'm here it was uh
i talked about this on on the podcast we
did the other day but it could have been
a traditional
hey dad this is the end goodbye i love
you but better call saul always makes
things a little messier than that so
like you alluded to it nacho can't
show that he's saying goodbye he can't
show his true feelings or else he'll
spook his father he'll know something's
up maybe he goes to the police and
everything blows up so it was a really
hard scene to watch
and it props to michael mando for
playing that perfect balance of i'm
feeling all of these things
i can't show them so it's all kind of
bubbling under the surface
and uh the line that got me for some
reason was when his father said you know
what you have to do you have to go to
the police and it's kind of like how
many times has he said that and uh for
some reason that hit me really hard well
it's like he we're so far past that
being an option now
yeah yeah but he doesn't know that he
can't know that you know yeah yeah if he
goes to the police his father's dead so
totally
yeah no i thought it was great i i was
actually
hoping that when he did call him his
father would even talk to him because i
think the last time we left him
he he thought that nacho had something
to do with
uh offering to buy his business for
trump
um
and he definitely wasn't interested in
that so
yeah i i was at least gratified to see
that his father would give him a
conversation here as much of a
conversation as this was right because
it's not a much of a conversation
there's
there's nothing there other than
what's going on behind the scene in
nacho's head and that's what makes it so
good
you know that kind of reminds me i don't
remember the exact context but i
remember in breaking bad when jesse's at
a real low and he tries he tries calling
his parents um and they do not give him
the time of the day they basically hang
up on him yeah
yeah the the you were talking about the
the line that hit you the line that hit
me was the what else is there to say you
know
and because it was so it's just such of
the you know it's just the the whole
thing of what nacho where nacho is all
wrapped up in one you know what else is
there to say what else is there to do
his dad has no idea that
his next move will be to sacrifice his
life you know what i mean but but you
know he understands that the situation
is never going to change unless it he
does something to change it and he just
doesn't have that information in front
of him of like what that really would
mean
at this point like he said we're way
past the point of him being able to just
call the police and
you know become a rat or whatever you
know that he
that he had one chance he he made a plan
that would involve him
running away with his dad he tried to do
it like you just said jim where he um
the last time these two people saw each
other that was because he had someone
come and give his father a really
good offer for his business so that he
could get out and they could just sort
of
do it without him knowing that they were
doing it and you know he it was never
going to happen
he's just gonna he's he's never going to
see things the way that nacho needs him
to see them
uh
did anyone i mean did anyone have that
interpretation that he was he was trying
to convey to his father that
you know we could still run away
or did you guys see this as just as a
goodbye as well
i did not get that impression i mean in
retrospect i think if the
if the father picked up on the subtext
and and was like well
do you have anything in mind is there
any way we can get out of this maybe
nacho would have taken the opportunity
but in the moment i didn't feel that
yeah i'll just second that did i didn't
see it that way at all
third yeah yeah yeah i thought it was i
thought it was pretty surprising
whenever he said but like you know you
have the actor's motivations and then
the characters motivations they're not
exactly you know the same for him to
play the
for him to play a
scene that is mostly with his face and
like you said
mostly about showing how everything's
bubbling under the surface because he
can't show it outwardly
you know he can think whatever he wants
because it worked you know what i mean
well and i think nacho here is in a
decisive
mindset but i see from an acting
perspective if you're really trying to
put yourself in the shoes of the
character
uh if i were nacho
i would definitely be hoping
that my my dad
seems open to this possibility or
suggests it on his own but i also see
myself not wanting to push it on him or
suggest it because i've suggested it and
and so many times before he shut it down
and in the end this is all my fault and
uh you reach a point where you're like
i'd rather die than be the reason my
father and i are have to live as
runaways for the rest of our life and
and we're constantly looking over our
shoulders
if i can just be decisive and take
ownership of my actions i will that said
there'd definitely be a part of me
that's like hoping maybe he gives me the
out
yeah and to put in context this is the
last conversation he's gonna have with
his father and i think he knows that
and so
he doesn't want this to end poorly right
he doesn't want this to be just another
one of those times when he comes to a
father and says we should run
uh and his father shuts him down and
says you know what you need to do
and every time if you if you watch what
he's doing here every time it gets to
that
point of the conversation nacho steers
it back to just kind of
i just wanted to see how you were doing
you know it's
it's something where he doesn't want
this last conversation to take any kind
of negative turn because he knows it's
the last one
yeah it's like like i was saying a bit
ago he's so protective of his father
like he he looks up to him in a way that
you know
only some i mean
he's in this extreme crazy situation so
it absolutely makes sense and
you know like
it sort of feeds into what we're going
to talk about next which is you know
this this trip there the time before his
waiting
sort of the last meal and all this stuff
i mean
you know that it's hard to imagine being
having that resolve you know we all love
our families we all love our you know
the people in our lives and things like
that
but you know when you're given the when
you're given the the two choices of of
your family or your actual life i mean
there's a survival instinct that is
pretty you know
pretty key in in being a human being so
it's wild to think about how he's going
through like there's a time period that
he has to wait after he makes his
decision
to just sort of let it sit in and know
there's nothing you can do about it you
know gil as my as your brother this has
given me a lot to think about
i'm hoping nobody rewatches this stream
to see when you said everyone loves
their family and i gave a kind of like
oh i saw it i saw it
but yeah i mean i i thought that you
know obviously mike's mike's
connection here is is is interesting and
and obviously they set that up over the
last especially over you know season
five um
where he was
he you know he he he was reaching out to
him because he of that with of their
past and maybe he could help him get out
of this life
and um
i thought you know whenever whenever
victor came down and it's sort of like
the the
you know just that cold
hey you know what you look too pretty
the boss doesn't like it you're gonna
have to get your ass kicked and
you know look the part for whenever we
execute you you know what i mean it's
like it's such a just a
ridiculous
thing to have to
hear and um you know i it kind of hit me
a little bit when mike was like no you
know i'll take care of that
and then victor walks away with a little
smirk on his face yeah yeah
i'm glad he got that box cutter
is this from the the drug stuff where he
was demanding you know it's six keys
instead of five or whatever and
victor like because everybody's about to
like shoot each other in those moments
right
victor seemed like having too much fun
with this yeah
i i was wondering that too because last
night after i finished you know doing
what i was doing i i re-watched the um
the closing shot because we were going
to talk about what's what's going on
with mike there and i noticed how just
how
i mean you can't miss the big smile on
victor's face whenever they're walking
away there
at the end and and then it reminded me
of this here like he he's he's really
happy to see mike
that mike accept beating his friend
space in you know what i mean like it's
it's really not subtle the way that
they're they're doing that with victor
here
and i was thinking what you know what
what what you said that you know it was
sort of like this is sort of the to make
that
box cutter thing just that much more
satisfying
but i think you know there might be
something to what you're saying too jim
because
it's like i i didn't notice it maybe so
much the first time but i definitely it
definitely jumped out to me the the
second time through that
victor doesn't he seems a little weirdly
you know you know excited about
everything that's happening here well
you know it's it's not very professional
uh
and and it kind of actually fits even
though victor in the long run is a
really minor character
it's the writers are so good at keeping
characters um consistent and well
integrated and if you think ahead
victor just kind of shows up out of
breath
uh right at gayle's doorstep right after
he was murdered and everyone sees him
there so he like of course he's a person
of interest and that's why he ends up
getting his throat cut open right
um
so so like this act the whole smirking
thing and just you know not keeping a
straight face it kind of fits the lack
of professionalism yeah
yeah and like you said they are kind of
um straight professionals that's the
whole they don't we don't learn anything
about those characters backstories or
what they do off the clock i mean
they're they're just there to be
you know pawns for for for gus to give
orders to and they and they'll pull them
off and you don't have to worry about
them because they're just all business
you know what i mean yeah i still got my
fingers crossed for that tyrus spin-off
i mean they could be fascinating people
we just never see it
i can't think of anything that we know
about them other than they're there and
they're ready to do whatever they
whatever needs done you know
so another thing i thought like the
whole trip across the border he was he
was essentially in a coffin um with a
little canteen
plenty of time to think about what
you're up against there while you're
while you're traveling on the highway
like i said it was a nice moment that
they shared him and mike with the um
with the drink and and you know just i i
think that you know we see
story-wise you see this is where you
know mike is making peace and and that
that comes into question
for some people later but i think that
this was for me this was the signal that
mike has accepted that this is the way
that it had to go
that
it could be worse and you know they have
a they have a plan you know they're
going to have him run and victor's going
to shoot him and it's going to be um
you know
quick and painless rather than long and
very painful as the salamancas would
have liked to have it and um
the big thing i guess when they arrive
at the spot is you realize that every
single person there you know how they
die you know their fate um it's all if
you've seen this if you've seen uh
in the both series in their entirety
then you you know we we know the ending
and
we only have there's only one big
question mark there and it's nacho and
you know there's really not much feeling
that it could get hopeful from that
point
do you guys have anything you want to
throw in there before we talk about this
final monologue
i mean my biggest question there was
what is mike talking about when he says
there's a million ways it can go wrong
or whatever he says
how does this sniper rifle solve
anything that could go wrong here
i saw that as
justification that he he said that as
kind of a fake reason why he had to be
there where yes having one more person
as competent as mike watching from a
distance
i guess it's one more safeguard but
really he just wanted to be there in not
just final moments
at least that's how i saw it
and
being ambiguous saying there's a million
ways this could go down it it it leaves
it up to gus's imagination
which it makes it actually more
convincing because he'll fill in his own
reasons why it could go wrong
my only like
feeling from like a plot perspective is
if something were to happen where nacho
would not sacrifice himself
and the cousins got a hold of him or
hector gets a hold of him and they start
forcing him to talk that mike might be
able to take him out and then plausibly
you could say well that's the
the people that were paying him and you
could try and make something up after
the fact but
that's kind of really the only reason i
saw mike to be up there from a plot
perspective
i would say it did seem a little
out of character for me that gus would
be directly challenged by mike and he
would just kind of nod his head and
accept it we we see mike
more frequently standing up to gus these
last couple episodes in ways that
to an extent feel a little bit like a
stretch to me but
maybe that's because i'm influenced by
by my perception of gus from breaking
bad and he's still evolving into that
person
yeah i i would say you know that's where
i landed jim what you were saying that
um the only way that makes sense as far
as mike selling it to
gus is insurance and as as in like he'll
take out
nacho if he has to
to make sure that
they can't make him talk like that's the
that's where i landed on it whenever you
know when i first watched it and and was
you know thinking about
the mechanics of it um
and and you know it it gets a little bit
unclear later
whenever in the moment whenever he sees
what actually happens but
you know they
i think i think that works for me
because it it makes he can sell that to
gus because you know if nacho were to
run away or
start shout like what if he started
shouting it was all gus
mike could just shoot him in the head
you know what i mean
so like there's there's those kind of
scenarios where he could he could kind
of sell it to gus of like you know
someone's in danger he's starting to say
the wrong things and but then there's
also a thing for mike which is that if
if it goes wrong and the salamancas are
going to start torturing this guy
then i can also take him out in that
situation as well i i think like
you know if mike's thinking straight he
knows he can't kill anybody else there
and there's just nothing there's no
there's no scenario where he does
anything but shoot nacho
i mean emotionally it might
it might be different you know in the
heat of the moment but
you know mike is pragmatic he you know
he thinks things through he he plans and
and he understands that there's no way
that they can walk away from they can
they can't escape there's no plan
there's no escape plan there's no way
that they can do that because
these people are all they're all part of
the cartel and they're all replaceable
you know what i mean individually
if they kill one of them somebody else
takes their place
and stacy and kaylee would never be safe
as long as you know mike was on the run
or somewhere else and he would never be
able to to be okay with that so
i think that's where you you know kind
of it kind of gets to uh and he and i
think what you're saying gill is also
true that he wanted to be there
you know
maybe maybe that's not something that
that was you know
spoken or a part of it you know of what
got him there but i think that
under the surface he he did want to you
know he wanted to be there in those last
moments he wanted to say goodbye to him
and all of that
well that nod he gives him could also be
part of that too right it's not just a
hey this is the last time we're going to
see each other and i respect you and i'm
sorry it went down this way it could
also be
don't worry i got you you know i'm not
going to let anything i'm not going to
let this go so wrong that you end up
tortured and and with a horrible death
yeah and i think that's also don't worry
about your father you know what i mean
like i will forfeit my life to protect
him and that's all we got you know i
mean like there's really nothing else
it's me and you versus the the cartel
and your dad is not in the game and i
will do whatever i can to try to stop
them and and that's the best you're
gonna get today
so you might as well take it
so yeah it it you know and obviously
there's been a lot said about the idea
that
you know his situation was inevitable
there there's no way that these guys are
going to let him get out of there
he does you know
he does he does manage to um
end his life on his own terms rather
than uh the way they wanted it to go
down
he delivers a
you know fantastic monologue
i was a little surprised that he he just
tossed it out there right away like like
not he didn't miss a beat telling him
that he was the one that put him in that
chair i did not see that coming as it
was as we were getting to it
and you know um
i i was also impressed that he managed
to
take he he managed to keep up his end of
the deal and like
making gus look like he really wasn't
involved
yeah with you know chicken man
yeah
so
what what do you what do you like what
is let's just i guess maybe we'll just
break it down to like what was your
favorite part of this and we'll just go
around and and we can all sort of chime
in on that
i mean for me it was uh sure
um for me it was
so if he was going to die and uh take
his own life here he kind of did as much
as he could do
to give himself gratification and
catharsis before that happened and for
me one of the best most memorable
moments of that was when he said to
hector you know for the rest of your
days when you're sucking down jello i
want you to think of me and you see
nachos bulging eyes and after a few
seasons of really only seeing him very
nervous and
between a rock and a hard place to
finally see him get to unload
that will stick with me forever that was
just a great gratifying moment
yeah it's almost like uh he gets a redo
on that situation where
uh
gus's guys had to had to shoot nacho a
couple times to make it look real when
he started becoming kind of a double
agent for them uh he kind of got a
second chance to approach that situation
in in a new way and he basically said
like screw you guys i'm going out
kind of on my own terms um and the the
specific moment that i loved in this
scene was just
when
that brief moment where he had the gun
up to bolsa's head and everyone it was
just this quick standoff and for a
moment after him just being crapped on
the entire series he's got everyone
there in the palm of his hand even even
for a split second
and and even mike felt it and he was
just like do it you know
felt good
uh for me it's the f-bomb
and not just because i'm crass which i
am but uh
you know they only get like one of these
a season right so if you're gonna use it
use it now uh this is perfect and i
think it works like not just
because hey it's an f-bomb but also
you need hector
to be sort of sidetracked by this cause
like you see nacho when he first says
like their plan he's very half-hearted
right he's just like oh it was these
guys they were paying me
whatever and it wasn't convincing
anybody's hector's over there ringing
his bell like crazy
he's pointing the gus nobody's buying it
right and so for him
to just go off script here and just
curse him out tell him i put you in that
chair think of me every day of your
miserable life
that is
i i feel like that's hector's trigger
like if anything is going to get
hectored to believe that something is
true it's getting pissed off
because he's he's impulsive he's
a wild dog so like
i felt like that he knew nacho knew in
that moment that this is the thing
that's actually going to work here and i
need to do it otherwise my father's
still going to die because hector knows
hector knows it's gus i need to just
piss him off and make him look the other
way
yeah i hadn't really considered that um
and i i think yeah that's a that's a
great point
yeah there really is a weakness
for hector
yeah
yeah and i i don't want to jump too far
ahead but i mean
i i really i mean i hated it but i loved
that he's just sort of impotently
firing bullets into his corpse at the
end yeah i just thought that was such a
great great way to show
how just how owned he was you know what
i mean like
he took that he took that right from him
you know i mean like they they they
they're
that creep like that just total
i mean awful awful
character human being whatever you know
what i mean just the just the worst of
the worst and
uh
you know there are a lot of bad ones in
this series
and you know what i mean and like you
just know how excited he was to
see this all play out you know what i
mean this is his big day out he spends
his time you know
literally eating jello over at the uh at
the old folks home and this is the big
day out to see you know somebody suffer
hopefully get his revenge on gus and in
the end he ends up just firing bullets
into you know a dead body that and
making no difference whatsoever
you know and think how much worse things
get for hector like it
eventually he he's off he's still stuck
in his wheelchair you can still barely
move
uh but he's his main caretaker is tuko
and they're living in the middle of
nowhere
uh i can't imagine he's getting the best
care i can't imagine his life is any
better in that situation and still he's
got to be thinking that freaking nacho
yeah i i there we have a super chat here
from steven mueller
nacho's death is a vote of confidence
for gus though mike vous for nacho and
in the end nacho proved him right
and yeah i mean that that's what you
know that
that's what i was saying you know it's
impressive that he's able to
not only
say his piece and and bring the
salamancas down but also
manages to you know
hold up his end of the deal pretty
flawlessly in that situation
it helps to undo some of the damage
caused by the verner situation where
mike put his confidence in him saying
don't worry gus he learned his lesson
he's not going to run or anything crazy
like that and then of course he does
mike takes care of it and now even
further mike has put his confidence in
nacho and everything played out pretty
flawlessly
not for nacho but for everyone else
well i mean you know it kind of worked
out for nacho given the um
the
the the options as much as it could yeah
yeah he
in the end he you know it was about him
doing the right thing for his father you
know
and and and and he did manage to do that
i mean i think that that if there's one
takeaway
he's a character who
you know he went out being the man he
wanted to be
and and he and he got it he got his
shots in at the end
in a situation where he was you know
that we've said multiple times already
was just inevitable there was nothing
that there was no way he was living but
he did
go out
and he made that
promise to himself that he was going to
do it in a way that would protect his
father and he was able to pull that off
go ahead well
speaking of protecting his father and i
i figured this is probably on the agenda
here but
um i know there's still a lot of debate
and a lot of questions over how safe is
his father in the long run
yeah this is one of the most uh most
asked questions in my comment section of
my
episode three video was
why is is uh nachos so
dumb to think that the salamancas aren't
gonna kill his father
so i i yeah i think we probably should
um
give our thoughts about that
he wants to go first before we get into
that 2d yeah yeah
why doesn't he kill juan balsa
uh because i have my opinions on that
and thoughts i i think it has to do with
nachos father
um i feel like
if you look at wan bulsa and how he's
been acting and how he's been kind of a
mediator between hector and gus the
entire time i feel like there's a layer
of protection that comes with juan balsa
being a part of the cartel
uh and being alive
and if nacho were to take him out i
think he knows his father is even less
safe
yeah um
and so i feel like he leaves mon bolsa
alive in order to have that extra layer
yeah i mean that was my that was my
thinking was that he you know
he couldn't really kill any of them
i mean he could he could have killed as
many of them as he could have but you
know in his mind if he thought if he was
thinking it through he was he would have
to come to the the realization that
anything that he does there that would
you know
make his father's situation more
precarious is the wrong choice
yeah i agree with that and i think it
speaks to um so so one of the one of the
arguments i've heard in favor of nachos
father is not safe is that the
salamancas might want to go after him to
send a message you mess with us not only
do we kill you but we kill your family
we kill your closest loved ones
but that would also send the message
don't bother to bargain with us and make
a deal because we're going to betray it
immediately after you sacrifice your
life
and i think jim to your point if juan
bolsa is kind of the mediator in those
sorts of cartel principles you would
want to keep him alive
and that would be kind of one
check under the column of things
protecting nachos father
yeah i know i think that's um i think
you guys are both on to
to the to the the truth of the situation
and
i think yeah when i'm listening to you
talking about it it's the idea of
balsa actually is the one who can can
offer protection from the cartel he's
the one that can actually keep the
salamancas on their leash because
if if eladio doesn't say that they can
go after um
not you know not just family if if he
doesn't if he you know then they can't
it'll be or they'll be killed you know
what i mean like you think of them as
complete loose cannons that don't answer
to anyone and
in reality hector has definitely pushed
those lines in his time when he was in
charge but
they they do answer to to the cartel
and and like you're saying gil if they
if if they make a deal
they do have to keep up their end even
if the you know even if the salamancas
feel like they're justif justified in in
making this this move
and it's all about money too you know
it's not really about it's not really
about the people
you know what i mean
like if if you're not earning then
you're going to be you're going to be
next on the chopping block so you know
what i mean
so okay let's let's bring that back then
to to this idea of is he actually safe
like
was it wrong for him to say that he
you know he he put hector in that
wheelchair because
it was really dangerous for his father
what do you guys think about that
and i think i think telling hector that
he put him in the wheelchair
does
to a certain degree put his father in
more danger because as we see with
hector firing bullets into a dead body
they're not above senseless violence so
there might be an emotional reaction of
not just dead but i still want revenge
on nacho i don't feel fully satisfied uh
so i was thinking
does it make sense to circle back to
nacho's father at some point and where i
could see it coming up is that they made
a pretty big deal back in three i think
where mike meets that woman anita in the
support group and finds out that her
husband passed away
but he just disappeared he went on a
hike she never found him again and one
of the things that really tortures her
is not having closure that makes him
think of the good samaritan that was
killed by hector so mike goes out in the
desert finds his body and anonymously
reports it to the police we have a
similar situation here where nacho's
father at some point is going to realize
that he hasn't heard from nacho in a
while
so we could see a scene tying a bow of
mike somehow getting word to not just
father not telling him the truth but
somehow getting him closure and maybe to
further tie that bow we also see mike
checking in on him to ensure his safety
or maybe there's a point where the
salamancas indicate they might kill
nacho's father and mike makes it clear
you can't do that
they're going to be severe consequences
if you do that and he continues to stand
up for him so personally in the story i
think nacho's father will be safe it's
hard for me to see kind of thematically
how i would look at the nacho story if
his father ended up dying anyway so i
think he's going to be okay
but i don't think that necessarily means
we won't see him again or this won't be
addressed further in a future episode
yeah and also mike is kind of uh he's a
pretty independent thinker and the fact
that he's still working for gus all
those years later in breaking bad says
something about their relationship
has has managed to continue and i think
uh if the salamancas choose to pursue
vengeance
on nachos father
i don't think mike alone is powerful
enough to stop this but i do think first
of all you have bolsa who's still alive
and has to play the role of peace broker
uh and you have gus who's extremely
powerful it might be time for the the
push and pull of mike and gus's
relationship mike has done so much maybe
some of the drama that's going to play
out is it
you know maybe gus actually needs to
step up
and do this for mike and for the the
bigger stability of everyone
do something to protect nacho's father
that's one of the reasons just the fact
that this death happened relatively
early in the final season makes me think
we're not done with this yet
let me offer a bit more tragic take
breaking bad is not above
kicking you when you're down i think
back to jane um
and how her death was so devastating but
then
they weren't
they they weren't uh satisfied just
leaving it at that or jane's dead they
brought her father into the mix
and they had him crash a plane
uh with his grief and complaints yeah
crushing each other
how how much
more
i don't know just like if they really
want to twist the knife on nacho and his
sacrifice you kill his dad anyway
and then you look back and see just how
futile
that sacrifice was i i you know it it
would be devastating but like i said i
don't think they're above that
you know you you very well could be
right and i i could just be hope like a
hopeless optimist
with no basis in reality because i think
you're you're totally right about
breaking bad not being afraid to to go
there
and also it would actually contribute to
mike's progression in terms of his story
in an interesting way because
uh by the time we see him in breaking
bad the more we learn about him the more
we see
uh yes he he cares a lot he he kind of
cares about jesse because of this sort
of paternalistic instinct he has but but
the the only people he really cares
about it seems are his his immediate
family who he wants to leave better off
uh
maybe if if uh nacho's father ends up
going off to belize uh it just further
cements mike as this character who who
can no longer
be pulled by his emotions or no longer
accept uh trying to be the good guy
anymore
yeah it's it's super fascinating because
you know you really don't know
for sure like it's not a this is not a a
story that you can solve because of the
way that they just don't really know
where they're going in the first place
and just
see how things turn out you know what i
mean
i i think that you make a fair point jim
about
you know breaking bad certainly it is
possible in this universe for them to go
that direction
and um you know i i i feel like whenever
i first heard
a lot of these reactions i was just like
but what but to what end you know that
that was my that's my knee-jerk reaction
is
to what end you know like how does that
improve
anything and you know
i can't see the the whole the whole
story
i think that
one thing that listening to you guys one
thing that came to mind is that you know
what i guess what's important in in
nacho's story in this desperate
situation this tragic ending
is what he had in his heart and and what
was going on
in his final moments and so on that end
he does have that you know i mean he he
did have he did achieve what he what he
set out to achieve
he he had mike who he trusts and and he
had his word that um he was going to
protect his father and he believed that
to be true
and that's pretty good that's you know
the whole idea is thrown out there there
are good deaths and there are bad deaths
and you know
this that put him in the category of it
being a good death
that he experienced
but yeah listening to you i i can see
that maybe there there is more to it
that there might be more to it but
i you know i guess what's what's fun
about it is that it's definitely not
um something you can just say oh yes i
know what they're doing here you know
and i think you both bring up good
points like pete you said to what end um
and adam you said maybe it would affect
mike and i think that's the thing right
in these shows
both better call sally and breaking bad
they
they will only do something if it's
going to affect a character uh
and that's what i love about these are
character driven dramas and yeah if if
hector just goes over to the
the upholstery shop one day and shoots
uh
nacho's father to death
and it's just one scene
and you think oh boy in retrospect
nothing nacho did mattered
it's not very satisfying you're right
pete uh
but like you like you said adam if it
affects mike somehow if mike sees this
or hears about it knows
that everything he did uh
was also in vain maybe it changes him
right maybe
yeah that that creates the character
that we see in breaking bad i could get
behind that but
i don't know we'll see like i said the
story they love to write themselves just
into corners and then write themselves
out of corners and
it'll be a lot of fun
yeah i
i just wanted to say real quick thanks
for the 4.99 joseph shulvin i don't see
a question i tried to scroll through
here to see if you follow that up and i
don't see one so
thank you for that
um
i did also want to check with you guys
how you are on time i'm not really in a
hurry yet but i just i don't want to
keep you captive if if if you need to
get out of here before
a certain time
yeah i'm good yeah good all right yeah
yeah because um
it's f because i yeah now i'm really
starting to get into this
to think about this on on
in a different way than i was able to
whenever i was just experiencing it and
like you know that that's the point i
wanted to make i think too about that
opening teaser and the way it's set up
and the idea of sacrifice
and how how
you know like i said earlier he gets to
that position he gets to that place way
before we can and then you know
the only other character that could
possibly care about this that's involved
is mike
nobody out like gus it doesn't you know
it's it's clear that him his henchmen
salamancas are probably upset that they
had this chance taken away from them but
really you know mike is the only one
that that has has
you know any kind of feelings about it
and um
you know
i i i guess we
do we want to get into this idea of what
he what he was thinking there whenever
he whenever we see him take take the gun
and he has it up against balsa's um
you know his temple and he says we see
mike say do it do we want to get go into
that right now you think
sure let's do it let's do it
yeah because i i
i have something bigger i guess like a
bigger picture to say but i guess that
this kind of makes sense to come here
first so
my my initial reaction to this was sort
of the same like you know he says
mike's watching
he sees him do it like he might you know
he sees him take the gun he has it up to
bolster his head
and in my mind mike's thought process
here is like oh man i'm gonna have to
kill nacho
you know i'm gonna have to take him out
because this is getting out of hand and
it's it's gonna end badly
but
he also sees this guy juan balsa and you
know he's connected to this cartel and
everything else that he's against he
sees him in this vulnerable vulnerable
position
so there's also the emotional reaction
of like
you know what i'd like to see that guy
die yeah you know i'd like to see nacho
take him out like i don't care about the
consequences wouldn't it be nice to see
juan balsa die today you know
that's how i read it
yeah which is it it doesn't make sense
in the long run to do that that'd be a
pretty messy situation but like you said
pete and this is adam i know when we
spoke about this you said the same thing
it was an emotional reaction in the
moment you know come on do it and then
when nacho ends up taking his own life
mike walks away thinking you know that
was the best possible outcome
yeah i think i think he was i think
there was real relief in him i think
when i went back to re-watch it after i
had seen this this come up so many times
and
that's the part that jumped out to me
was the relief and like oh thank god it
ended the right way you know
so he wouldn't look like that if he
didn't really feel something about
just wanting to go the nuclear option
even though it made no sense and it
would have had terrible consequences and
to me that really makes it
a lot more compelling you know it makes
it you know it makes it very very
realistic because this happens in a few
seconds and you know you don't always
get to
have your best thought first you know
what i mean
yeah i feel like this is like a pretty
dramatic display for mike too just
saying do it in this moment you know i a
lot of time he's just like
that's his only reaction to something
he'll shake his head
for a second and
that's it that's how you know mike is
disappointed or mad uh and this you do
get a little bit more you get a look of
relief yeah the many faces of mike
armitron
yeah
i have a quick um
super chat here
raquez muhammad
thank you for the 499 he says do you
think tuko will find out nacho and mike
were behind his arrest
um you know they alluded to the idea
that that mike couldn't be there
physically because
the the salamancas knew him um that did
come up earlier in this
i i don't know that tuko i mean a lot of
people are
asking questions about tuko coming and
i guess he's about 10 months out until
he's supposed to get out of prison i'd
right now i don't really
anticipate him playing a big role in
this season that could change as we get
closer to that time but um
what do you guys think is he going to
find out about nacho and mike i mean it
seems a little bit
hard for that to happen because mike
openly works with gus
you know going on and and tuko is
obviously in charge in the breaking bad
timeline so so what do you guys think of
that
yeah that's got to be what he's got
victor and tyrus around for right to
interface with hector or juan or people
that
uh
yeah that would know mike if if mike
were to show his face so probably not
yeah it also kind of feels like too big
a can of worms to open up uh now that
we're approaching the end game here
yeah that's what i that's what kind of
that's what i keep thinking about with
tuko is like how do you make him
how do you make him um vital to what's
happening right now because he's
completely disconnected from it other
than his familial connection
and you know and everything else has
been building on this slow burn to this
point it's sort of like he'll feel he'll
feel out of place if he really starts to
have an important um
you know take a larger role in the story
i think
plus he raymond cruz he plays that so
big and he and he's such a like
dominating kind of presence it just
right now it doesn't feel like it's
going to be a good fit for where we're
headed
does anybody else have a anything to add
to that
no
do you want to see him kind of where we
pick up with uh hector
in breaking bad do you want to see him
come back to usher hector
out to uh the desert where he ends up
yeah i mean just got to fill in that
blank
whether it whether we actually see it or
or there's at least some explanation
there
yeah yeah i mean i think that you know
they've laid the they laid the track
there that you know we know how we know
why he's in prison we know that you know
how long he's supposed to be there for
he had his his you know stay extended
because of
poor behavior while he was in there
imagine
[Laughter]
um you know it's like we you know
we can see
i don't know that they have to but it
it might be nice you know i mean there
could be a good reason for it
we have another super chat here um
joseph shovin again so sorry if that was
a mistake before
thank you for the 499 once again and
thoughts on it was me it was ignacio
line
i think jimmy will rat on lalo and jimmy
could be ratting on him while working
for him
um
anyone want to pick that up and run with
it
yeah i'll say um we put our heads
together the other day to think through
that line like we do after every episode
where we get any more kernel of context
or what it could mean uh and for anyone
in the chat that needs a quick reminder
basically when
walter and jesse kidnapped saul goodman
in his debut episode on breaking bad
uh
saul's trying to figure out who's
kidnapping him right now and he thinks
that they were sent by lalo and he says
it wasn't me it was ignacio
so adam alluded to the idea earlier that
right now jimmy has the choice do i rat
on lalo or do i be a friend of the
cartel and maybe he finds some way to
dance in between that so
our thought was that maybe he does
something in the realm of ratting on
lalo something in the the vermin kind of
vicinity exactly but somehow blames it
on nacho like maybe nacho knew he was
going to die so he put an anonymous tip
out there or something but somehow jimmy
gets away with it and the word on the
street is it wasn't jimmy it was nacho
it was ignacio but now he's afraid maybe
someone's figured out the truth
but there's 10 episodes left so who
knows next episode could completely
change our perspective on it
man it feels like it it's going by so
fast but
it's i actually feel like that same
sense of relief that mike had
when you said ten episodes like oh yeah
there's still ten episodes there's don't
no no worries about the time frame yet
or anything
and you know i i think whenever
you just were talking about that i was
just thinking about how much
conversation there's been about this
this line and i wonder how that
i wonder how that they you know vince
and peter and the other writers that how
they think you know how much that
how that makes them feel when they think
about like a total throwaway line
something that was it was
inconsequential just something that he
had to say at the moment and the way
that people
myself included talk about this line and
what it means and all this time later
you know it's like what 13 years since
that that first was uttered on tv
and people have been talking about it
you know for at least since better call
saul came out
as far as what you're asking here though
joseph you say uh
you think he's gonna rat on him i i
didn't feel like there was any chance
that he was gonna rat on him whenever i
watched the episode for the first time i
thought that
one of the things that stood out in this
episode to me was that jim jim jimmy is
like
he's driven by being validated by what's
going on with kim like he really does
you know of course he loves her they're
in a relationship but but
and where he's at right now in in his
psyche is like he's looking to to kim a
lot more than than what you would expect
you know i was i was kind of shocked
whenever he asked
what he should do you know he didn't say
i'm going to do this or what do i think
about this or lay anything else he just
says what what should i do basically you
know and that seemed really
un
or on jimmy in that moment and so i i
thought that
they might try to do something
you know to make it
make it to keep the heat off him or
something like that but i just didn't
think he was gonna rat
for a second
did any of you guys think that he might
rat
i'll say i don't think he would rat in
response to this current situation
maybe something happens in the next 10
episodes where it's not pure jimmy
coming clean and saying what happened
but if there ends up being a chess match
between lalo mike gus jimmy and kim
maybe at some point there's a move that
makes sense which involves something
that looks like ratting i i could see
him
finding some some way to skirt the line
or something that involves speaking with
authorities even if it's if it's not
technically ratting but but you know
playing his hand in in a certain way
it's hard to predict get into specifics
at this point but i don't think he's
above it if he thinks it'll give him
some kind of advantage
um
yeah i mean i like that point about him
following kim's lead right now because
jimmy isn't jimmy at the moment you know
jimmy has been through a traumatic
experience uh
he sees that
he his his game was up and when lalo
came to his house
uh at the end of season five and
he was done lalo knew knew what was up
uh and kim was the only person there who
could talk him out of that situation so
i feel like he is leaning on her and
trusting her a little bit to guide him
through this
yeah
yeah and i think as far as the line is
concerned i i do think and i mentioned
this in my video i do think there's
still more to be done you know i mean
like to to flesh out why he said what he
said there i don't think that that the
jimmy right now would
would say that yet maybe you know like
ignacio he doesn't have any he hasn't
had any contact with him other than to
you know have him become lala's lawyer
in in last season uh
he has no reason to bring that name up
at that point i don't think unless he
hears about what happened or something
like that
and of course
they've kind of made a point to say that
jimmy will be afraid of lalo and think
that he's alive even if he knows for
sure he's dead like uh vince gilligan
and peter gold you know
had said that more than once at this
point
so you know what i mean like
he's a specter he's he haunts jimmy and
i'm not sure that we
jimmy's definitely scared of him right
now and he thinks he's dead
so i'm not sure how he he he uh reaches
that specter kind of status you know
we have another one here from
mod mary thank you for the 9.99 and it's
related so i wanted to just go right
into this one
when will kim and jimmy find out lalo is
alive love your streams and content
thank you
anybody have a guess on when they might
find out that he's still alive
when he shows up
in their living room or will it be
something else
you know they might never find out
uh like you said it could be this
spectre thing so even if jimmy has all
the confidence in the world that lala's
dead if he has reason to believe that
lalo or his people would
be pissed at him about something
uh you can you know i imagine you could
never totally shake the the possibility
that this guy's still out there looking
for you
just like a skinny pete and badger look
lurking in the shadows with their laser
pointers
i i have the feel i don't have a
prediction on when it's going to happen
but getting into how it's going to
happen
uh i
we had that great scene between kim and
lalo last season
and
i've seen a lot of people mention the
idea that lalo may have walked away
somewhat impressed by kim
and so i do wonder if there is another
meeting and it isn't purely antagonistic
like it was the first time
uh
are you in the camp of uh they get
married and run off together that's
where i was going where it is kim and
during breaking bad she's with lalo
somewhere
uh no i don't think that but there could
be some
bizarre alliance at some point where
maybe jimmy and kim aren't entirely
willing partners but they kind of have
to be
uh and there is uh you know so it's hard
to predict exactly but to quote mike
whatever it is it's not gonna go down
the way you think i mean yeah maybe this
proof that lala is talking about
ends up being the thing that ropes
uh
kim or both of them back into this
and we we have one here uh we can all i
think we can all
uh
pitch in on you know give our thought on
uh gg g
gj nelson thank you for the 15 that's
very generous small thing but was it
wasn't baby powder
right
actually i think it was
why would it be that's that's my biggest
question why would it be it's saul
goodman
yeah what
i got the accent for sure
yeah what do you think gail baby powder
or was it the devil's dandruff i mean if
it's
never gonna i just used that term
earlier today i mean if it wasn't baby
powder
would that mean that kim doesn't kim
thinks it's baby powder even though
jimmy knows okay so see jimmy nodding oh
you know i didn't even think about that
yeah i have to rewatch the scene with
that added you know idea
that would be interesting because right
now we're seeing jimmy looking a little
bit more meek and lacking confidence but
it's totally in character for him to
take the scam an extra step further
without kim's knowledge we've seen him
do it time and time again and he's like
trying to appease kim right now as best
he can so he thinks he's going above and
beyond making it real drugs and then
kim's like that was baby powder right
and he's like uh yeah totally right
yeah and this kind of this kind of
transitions into this next uh super chat
too again from stephen mueller 499 thank
you
kim is the walter white of this series
good corporate citizen breaking bad
jimmy is jesse aloof but gets out alive
um
you know
the the thing about the walter white
comparison that i think is is is key is
that
walter
walter in my in my reading of it you
know walter has was always heisenberg
the situation
brought it out it you know it gave him
the chance to to be that um
so if we say that kim is the walter
white that means that she has something
under the surface that's always been
there
and
this this this uh you know this the set
of circumstances the way things played
out
allows that to come to the surface what
do we think about this uh you know
just
you know quick take not not really like
you know thinking about it too deeply
what do you how does that hit you
whenever you hear that kim is the walter
white of this series
my wife had an interesting take on this
uh after we stopped our podcast
and she pointed out that kim has started
smoking inside the house now
and if you look at kim she's always
smoked but she's always been in the
parking garage or out on the balcony
um and and then i
i connected that to walter white and how
his wardrobe changed over the course of
that uh series
and i think about that red wine colored
shirt he had
uh and how that sort of signified to me
the change in walter white and i think
there is something to that right like
kim
i mean we can see in her actions she's
definitely gone over the line and i
think you know the visual storytelling
here with the cigarette and smoking
inside is very much telling us that like
yeah she is more akin to the walter
white and i do think
jimmy is a bit of a jesse at this point
certainly
yeah i
you know i go back and forth on it
because
you know one of the reasons is honestly
because i don't expect them to do
exactly the same thing they did in their
last series you know it's kind of hard
to it's kind of hard to be like and and
then they got there in a different way
and all that but you know you kind of
think that they might have had a
different idea or a different take on
things and jimmy obviously i think was
you know he
he's he doesn't he didn't have this big
crazy
thing that happened in his life that
that forced him to confront
hit you know
who he was and how he wanted to go out
you know i mean he he slipped really you
know he sort of was slipping jimmy he
sort of just sort of got on the the
slippery slope and
slowly changed into saul goodman
and um you know
it could it could very well be the case
i mean there's a lot of things if you're
willing to to look at them
i think that that's a great observation
about this
the smoking because i think that stood
out right away you know like you saw
that at first when she did that whenever
jimmy was in the desert and and
he she was really worried and you can
understand that
but now you know we see her that she
continues to do that and it makes you
kind of go back and think about that too
like what was the real thing that was
going through her head with jimmy when
jimmy was in the desert because
it kind of gets pushed out it kind of
gets pushed aside but she she told him
without any
you know she just told him straight up
that she wasn't into it him going to to
deliver the money to be the bag man
and he he didn't pay any attention to it
he just sort of let it go and and
there's there's definitely a possibility
that something changed in the way that
she sees him and the way that they they
you know the way that their relationship
is structured like what what her goals
are as a parent as a you know compared
to what their goals were together kind
of thing
but man it's so hard to uh it's so hard
to think of kim
you know like i i get the idea that she
has this sense of justice you know this
underlying sense of justice and and
we're seeing that she thinks that she
can dole that out which is a pretty
crazy
escalation for the character
and you know she could say jimmy
deserves to get knocked down you know
knocked down a a a notch after what some
of the things that happened in the last
couple episodes but
it's still really hard for me to imagine
that she just she just uh
scams him or or does something like
really diabolical towards the end
and you know i mean if they can pull it
off i'll i'll love watching it don't get
me wrong there i'm not saying that it
would ruin it it's just like it's hard
to the way that the character's been set
up it's really hard to kind of think of
of it going that way
there is that i mean
and there's a second point here about
jimmy i i i don't know um
jimmy is like in such a weird spot right
now i'm looking forward to seeing how he
he reemerges over these next couple of
episodes because i'm really not sure
what's going on with him at the moment
yeah it's funny because we call him
aloof here but i probably wouldn't have
said that about him a season ago i think
this is a sort of new thing for him so i
definitely see some parallels right now
but i wouldn't have necessarily seen
them you know pretty recently
and with kim compared to walter i think
a big question is motivations
and for walter i think a lot of it was
pride and ego for kim it's a sort of
revolt against people like howard hamlin
getting all the power
where other people that can't just
afford or get the right opportunities
end up punished by the system and so
she's doing a sort of robin hood thing
uh that's i think at least how she sees
herself right now and where will that
lead her she could end up in a similar
place as walter white um but pete you
triggered a thought for me when you
talked about jimmy versus kim
and i do think there might be some
reckoning to happen between them where i
don't know if kim fully appreciates the
difference in motivation between them
um where the way she looks at the world
like there's justice and going after
howard hamlin
i don't necessarily think jimmy thinks
of it that way and i think that's a lot
of the reason why he is sort of aloof
right now and kind of along for the ride
and a little bit hesitant in this whole
process
um i keep thinking about a scene
right after her car accident when jimmy
finds kim watching all those tapes from
blockbuster and she's watching to kill a
mockingbird
and she says that you know she wanted to
be gregory peck didn't everybody want to
be gregory peck you know do the right
thing fight for justice and jimmy kind
of wrote it off as that was more chuck's
thing so there is definitely a
difference in morality between the two
characters
and
i feel like kim might kind of see it but
i don't know if she's fully acknowledged
that yet and i wonder what will happen
if or when that happens and i also think
that makes kim more dangerous because
uh it's one thing for for a slip and
jimmy to
commit a chicago sunroof because he just
doesn't like someone and it amuses him
to to get like petty revenge it's
another to do something like that and
see it as almost like you're you're
cosmically justified in doing it and
you're you're sort of the judge jury and
executioner of morality from situation
situation so
uh
kim is becoming a scarier character by
the day
yeah it's kind of a concept of vigilante
justice right
that she's on yeah
yeah
it's it's fascinating and we have
another one here from word nerd 7-eleven
thank you for the ten dollars
thoughts on where where can kim ends up
dead or alive
i i have to say the same thing i said
before i can't imagine her ending up
dead doesn't mean it can't happen but my
mind is is simple in that way that it
just doesn't want to look at that
reality
and um you know
i i
i do believe that that phone call that
that that's alluded to in the 405 teaser
um that takes cl you know that i feel
like that is her that's calling and
that's one of the main reasons why i
think that she at least survives
through the breaking bad timeline
what do you guys think dead or alive
it's a binary
oh boy yeah schrodinger's kim she's both
just thinking that yeah
i don't know and part of that
that's kind of great right like i yeah
we don't know she could be dead she
could be alive
it leaves a bit of mystery in a series
that otherwise could be pretty devoid of
it and it is with certain characters
right with the vast majority i'd say of
characters
yeah and you know the the you mentioned
the phone call and i do think
when we see that flash forward of uh
saul cleaning out his office getting
ready to to disappear with the vacuum
guy
uh and he he's asking francesca remember
on this date you'll be here to answer
the phone at this time that day is
jimmy's birthday
uh i can't think of anyone else he'd be
expecting to call besides kim but you
know this show could throw us a curve
mike calls him on his birthday every
year from beyond the crowd happy
birthday jimmy yeah
yeah i i mean
i like i think what you said jim is is a
great uh
you know the the the great truth of the
whole thing and i think we all
experienced this when we were
on our re-watches i know i talked to all
you guys uh you know about re-watching
and some of the things that we had
some of the revelations we had and
things like that and and it's amazing
that it can be everything can still be
on the table like kim could absolutely
die
she could be walter white she could you
know
set jimmy's world on fire and he might
be sitting in a golden
you know mansion just trying to
compensate for the the pain that he he
feels in his heart for how how how badly
he was mis you know
mistreated by this the true love of his
life
or they could get back together in omaha
and go off and have a happy ending
they're all equally as possible
could she live in that
house i think no that's been my saying
my you know
i i have some thoughts about that we
could we could we could detour into that
if you want to a little bit but
just as far as that question no i don't
think that it's possible that she lived
inside that house
oh okay i just thought from a style
perspective that's what i'm saying i
just don't think it i can't see it i
can't see her waking up every day and
going into the bathroom and using the
golden toilet like
yeah
you know i i felt the same i said the
same thing last week i felt the same way
initially until we saw the conversation
where she was like what kind of car
would saw goodman drive saw goodman
would have a nice office so i could
picture her saying what kind of toilet
would saul goodman have
and just propping up this false life of
opulence and the only downside is she
has to enjoy like an awesome mansion
but uh you know she has to do it
maybe well the thing about it is that
and what i think is so fascinating about
that in and i i did a short video about
it because um peter gould was talking
about how not only was it filled with
easter eggs but it was filled with
future easter eggs or pre-easter eggs
like everything inside there we kind of
saw that with the painting the painting
comes down the stairs that was in her
apartment and then we see it in this
last episode that they're putting their
stick sticky notes on there the same
with the the beanie baby it it popped up
in the and the most recent teaser you
know the exact beanie baby that we saw
inside that
and you know the thing that i keep
thinking about with that is that it's
behind closed doors
he doesn't need that you know i mean
like nobody's seeing that and getting
impressed and hiring to be hiring him to
be their lawyer
it seems like it's it's this just you
know i i can see kim pushing for
him to have this this persona that he
puts out in the world as saul goodman
but i can't see why they would have to
keep that up behind closed doors right
he's not inviting walter white or any
other cartel members to his house for a
meeting so uh i think you know if i had
to put my money on it i'd say she's not
in that house
but once i heard that conversation it
put the little inkling in my mind of i
don't know maybe
or or it's uh kind of kim's influence
lingering in his head right so
does that look like the house of jimmy
mcgill like to me it does not but does
it look like the house of of a jimmy
mcgill who fully committed to the saw
goodman persona
in both in public and in private maybe i
mean you see you know this like that
inflatable statue of liberty you see the
constitution behind him in his office
and and just how opulent everything
there looks um
maybe he's just kind of through and
through committed to that persona
yeah and there's the idea that you know
he he he started out
it was a bit and then he he became it
over time i guess you know what i mean
um
but uh man it's just it's just so over
the top i think it was a great way to
start the season and i think about it
after every episode like what
how do i feel about that now like i have
to you know sort of think about
you know how how to change my thoughts
on it after each one
we have another uh super chat here from
morgan holiday
five dollars thank you for that d.a
erickson mentions how the system is
broken
kim doesn't verbally acknowledge this
but she fully believes she can use this
to her moral goals
um
she can use this to her moral goals what
do you make of that
anybody have a take on this one
well i think that goes to what we were
all saying earlier about how
kim justifies her actions in a very
uh
holier than now mentality the system is
broken
and she's there to fix it doing whatever
it takes
and to adam's point i think that makes
her very dangerous because
where jimmy's justification this person
wronged me that enables him to perform a
chicago sunroof
in kim's case it enables her to destroy
a man's career i mean she's trying to
just bruise him and leave him standing
um but
i think it will allow her to justify
darker and darker actions
yeah the best i mean you can have good
intentions but that doesn't mean that
everything's going to go the way that
you have it planned out
obviously [ __ ] gets out of control
that's how it works
but yeah no i i think you're right i
think that that's what what
morgan's talking about here and
it's a pretty good setup i mean um
you know if you have things if you're
the hero in your own story and you have
it sorted out in the way that you know
you can't really be wrong for doing what
you're doing
it allows you to do all sorts of things
doesn't it
and we have another quick one here from
joseph shulvin 199. thank you do you
think the bcs and bb timeline will
overlap i would say
not
not
completely i think we'll see overlap i
think we'll see some some more flash
forwards to to the breaking bad timeline
but i don't think it'll be like
we're gonna skip four years from right
now up into that episode like with flash
forwards or whatever or time jumps i
mean i think um
the story will end before we get there
and it'll make sense
for how things were the way they are
when we when we do
anybody have anything uh
think about that differently or
what do you think
i think i was kind of shaking my head
but sort of jokingly just because like
we were talking earlier about peter
gould and vince gilligan speaking pretty
openly about the show so it's no secret
at this point that walter and jesse are
going to show up at some point so we at
least know there's going to be some kind
of overlap how much i think it's a big
open question i'm very curious to see
what they do and how logistically they
connect the shows
do you guys have a favorite idea of of
hallow and jesse come back i mean i i i
kind of vaguely think it's going to be
in a in a flash forward and don't really
have much else
to say like i don't really have a i
don't have like a pet um
idea of like i'd like to see
do any of you
i mean it almost has to be
high school for jesse right
or pretty close to it if not
i mean and right now where the story's
at he's he's certainly he would probably
yeah be like 16 or something right wow
yeah
and that'd be tough to follow yeah
how's the de-aging the
technology along
yeah
i i mean i did hear i did hear from
people who were really watching
you know
the the the actor that he he lost a lot
of weight around the time that he was um
supposed to be
filming
like there was a noticeable
you know there was a noticeable change
in appearance that people had noticed
but it never got out that he went to
albuquerque and and so now people were
going back and putting it together and
said oh that's when he went
was whenever he you know he he dropped
this crazy amount of weight or whatever
but yeah i mean i just think it i just
want it to make sense you know right i
want to cheer i want to i want to i want
to fist pump in the air whenever
walter white and jesse come on screen i
do hope they're kind i do kind of hope
that they're together like i don't i i
think
there's a special kind of feeling that
that would elicit instead of just
seeing one at one point and the other
another point um
and i just think it yeah it just sort of
has to be a flash forward but i i don't
i don't have a a pet um idea of what
would be like the best
case scenario
yeah i guess i just hope it doesn't feel
shoehorned or too overtly fanservicey
and i mean i have every reason to
believe it'll they'll pull it off well
uh but that's just my main concern yeah
yeah the unit's fair you know
the only couple things for me would be
one i feel like everything that needs to
be said between jesse and walter has
been set at this point especially with
the flashback and el camino
so whatever it is i just hope it does
something to help us further understand
the jimmy slash saul goodman character
that they're on the show to serve the
grander purpose of better call saul
and then in terms of pet ideas i think
it would be fun
if they find a way to show us something
we already saw in breaking bad and then
somehow kind of meld it into something
new i think of back to the future too
where you would see marty mcfly and then
behind him see scenes from the first
movie so just from like a geeking out
kind of perspective i feel like that
would be fun to see and it also feels
like the kind of thing if you listen to
the insider podcast the kind of thing
they would have a lot of fun doing
yeah
yeah i i i can i can back that up i
think that's a good idea i do kind of
hope that they do something like that i
mean people get a little bit crazy with
it whenever they're talking like they
want to see everything from another
perspective i think there should be a
limit to how much of it they would you
know actually do but
a couple of key things would be would be
a fun thing and in in what you said i
think is really important it has to be
in service to saul's story or kim's
story or i guess maybe to a lesser
extent mike's i mean
walter white and jesse their story has
been told there's not
it's not the job of better call saul as
a series to do that you know what i mean
so
i i do agree that it needs to be in
service of of of the narrative that
we're following now
not just to to add something to the the
original series
do you have anything jim on that
uh maybe saul's the attorney for
whatever breakup happened between walter
and elliot
um
yeah i didn't think i hadn't thought
about that
because they have that company together
so that's true
yeah
yeah i mean
well i mean saul is such a he's such a
what's her name betsy cattleman is is
wrong about so many things
but her her
her her take on jimmy being a a
lawyer that people that guilty people
hire
it may not be true at the moment but you
know it definitely becomes true and
we're seeing that and it happened right
now and um
yeah that's why it's a little bit hard
to see those worlds cross except when
they actually do cross in the way that
they did
i wanted to to address this real quick
jake statler thank you for the five
dollars it says is it just me or was
the intro sequence you know the opening
credits different
it lacked the statue of liberty and had
two cigarettes and a balanced scale
there's a different one for each episode
there's 10
10 different ones
and the statue of liberty's the first
and so on so the thing that they do with
the title sequences and they have been
doing each season is they get a little
more beat up like a vhs tape would if
you kept watching it over and over again
you know with the series open with gene
watching re-watching his vhs
commercials you know saw goodman
commercials and
so what they do with the sequence every
every season is they just sort of beat
up the the quality of the recording each
time
and it's an interesting thing because
there's only 10 of them and there's 13
episodes this season so they might have
to come up with a few new ones that we
haven't seen yet
you know i love the way this show
rewards attention to detail uh
giving you something just like this this
little tidbit in the starting of each
episode to watch and track from episode
to episode and from season to season
um
it rewards you for paying attention and
and i have a bunch of these little pet
things such as the starting that that i
just like i'm always looking at them and
trying to see how it changes and what
they're showing us like the other big
thing for me personally is the uh like
the fish tank that lives on their
kitchen counter and just like one day
something's gonna happen to that fish
tank i think or or a minimum you see
lalo tapping on it like it's there for a
reason
it's a little reward for people who are
who are trying to to just digest
everything in this show right everyone's
wondering where kim is during breaking
bad but i've had my eye on that goldfish
i don't know what's the life expectancy
of a goldfish
depends how well you take care of them
are they all right
yeah i don't know the answer to that
question but i i assume that it's not
very long like that that it's probably
close to that um already
so um
i guess this is a point where we can you
know if you've got if the people
that are here keeping things going in
the chat if you have questions you can
start lobbing them in our directions
um
did you guys have did any did any i
guess let's go from from you know
is there anything that that we didn't
talk about that you would like to talk
about before we just jump into questions
and we'll start jim what about you is
there something that that
we haven't touched on yet that that's
sticking out for you on this episode
uh one one question i had at the end of
last episode that i think paid off this
episode is who was tailing jimmy at the
end of it
um
we see that you know big brown mike
looking car drive away
uh
when they when they leave the
cattlemen's uh tax retreat
so i was wondering if that was maybe the
ada's uh
i don't know lawyers or someone from
their
workforce tailing him
so uh one one thought i've heard
bouncing around so i like the idea it
could be ada related especially now that
we've seen more happen with that story
so that i think that's a pretty good
theory another theory is
uh you know howard's a smart guy he
already knew saul was was kind of
tormenting him like with the bowling
balls and sending the prostitutes then
when he was at lunch with uh
um
you know
oh i thought maine
yeah yeah exactly cliff maine so
uh howard's probably already realizing
there's a good chance uh
jimmy is that is
up to some shenanigans here uh which
also something i wanted to bring up when
someone asked about the baby powder
so there's a chance that jimmy put some
real cocaine in there there's also a
chance that they did put baby powder and
one of the kind of unspoken parts of
their plan that we're not privy to is
they want howard to suspect uh saul for
whatever reason and so it could be
the plan is in motion howard's on the
case he sent out a private investigator
to follow them or something
uh there's a lot of different ways it
could go but but i think
we're not always totally in the loop as
to what they're up to and there's often
several
steps ahead of us as viewers yeah i
remember noticing that when they
discussed their plan the camera kind of
cuts to an external shot of the
restaurant and you see jimmy and kim you
can't hear what they're saying so the
entire time we've been watching their
plan kind of unfold i keep thinking
there's going to be
some twist or some unexpected turn
and you know i think back to chuck in
the courtroom where he keeps accusing
jimmy of all these things you know he
faked the billboard stunt he was behind
this whole thing here he's been behind
everything and chuck is correct about
everything he's saying but he ends up
looking like an insane person
and maybe there's something similar
going on with howard where he catches on
to jimmy but his accusations
just
amount to nothing in comparison to what
it would look like to an outside
observer prostitutes came to your lunch
we found these drugs in your locker you
sound like a crazy person accusing jimmy
so that's something i've been thinking
about
yeah i mean my my initial thought when i
watched the first trailer was that
there's no way that they're they're
they're just
not setting him up you know the the idea
in the first trailer was that he was
going to try to bring a case against
them or he was building the case
and in that situation i thought well
that must be something they want howard
to do because they're the ones that are
are running the scam on him and and
they're not going to do that in a way
that he he you know he figures it out
and gets the advantage unless he's
supposed to
and it's getting more complicated now i
mean like the the this guy in the car
you were talking about
the popular theory at that time was it
was related to to howard um and like
then as you said the ada now is is a
possibility
and um
also gus because gus is paranoid and he
he knows that you know mike told him
that lalo was
you know
they were looking anywhere lalo might
show up and anybody he might contact and
they know jimmy would be one of those
people if if lala was able to get back
into the country so
you know there's a lot of different
options there
um
uh this i was looking at this question
was the fish from the veterinarian yes
that was definitely a thing that
happened and well he didn't he bought it
so that he could go see the veterinarian
and uh
you know get a get a a criminal to hire
a criminal
does anyone remember exactly what that
first introduction was about
no
you know it's funny because what i do
remember is the vet was very concerned
with how jimmy was taken care of
you can't leave it in a bag like that
you need to give it space
yeah i remember that part too that's
what stands out to me
i can't remember why he went there uh
i mean he went he went there to get ira
for the uh
you know the state of the bavarian boy
bavarian boy heist or whatever
but um
i can't remember if that was the first
time or not then i think that i want to
say that was why he was there but yeah
we need to fact check that
i do want to add uh just the vet
characters one of my of this just
awesome universe of interesting
characters the vet is one of my
favorites
and uh i randomly went to see a stand-up
show in new york like last year and the
actor who plays the vet joe de rosa
happened to be performing that night and
he was hilarious
um and it i just
the way that this ship this whole
universe takes comedic actors and and
gives them just the perfect role uh
never ceases to impress me
yeah
do we think there's gonna be a
veterinarian
uh appearance in this final um
final season
it's funny i thought you were going to
ask do we think there's going to be a
veterinarian spin-off after breaking so
i would watch that i would watch it i
would definitely watch 100 wood
i was not that invested in watching
assault spin off and look how that
turned out i mean
it's amazing
is it possible that the vet is how we
find out about the disappearer
it could be yeah sort of
of the underworld
yeah exactly
this question here do you think alvarez
makes an appearance that was something
that i meant to bring up earlier do you
i again i for me like
in my my small small mind that that is
just
really loved the ending that they gave
nacho
you know i just don't really see
why that's all that interesting you know
like
do you guys think that there's going to
we're going to see the salamancas take
their revenge on this this patsy alvarez
down in peru
anyone
i i have my doubts about it
yeah
yeah we we know there has to be some
kind of goose chase there there has to
be something that links where we start
with gus and juan
in breaking bad
and where they are now so maybe
i mean couldn't that put a
i mean could they want to check out
nacho's story and
i don't know go capture someone from
alvarez's camp and be like hey there's
nacho working with you guys
or something like that i'm not sure yeah
i mean i don't think hector even
believes the story
so
you know maybe in there maybe to him
it's not even worth pursuing
but who knows i mean it's so hard to to
predict what's in his head when all you
get is the the bell
and his his facial expressions
yeah
here's one for
[Laughter]
uh yes yes we are yeah
and if you uh if you listen to uh saw
cast you might hear a couple more of our
brothers so there's a few of us running
around yeah
oh yeah i've only met the two but i've
heard i've heard mention of more
brothers in the family
we're like the salamancas
when you need one a new one just shows
up
get to the end of season four and there
and things are starting to get a little
a little uh a little tired in the on
that side of the story so you need some
you need to pull out a new salamanca
there's one adam would be the wallow
he's really good at cooking so he's
lollo
and i have a great vertical leap so
um
let's see here i i i'm terrible at going
through the the comments and talking at
the same time
i'm trying to pick something out here
what do
i i was thinking about um
again about that
about that um
that board that they have in in
you know on the back of the painting oh
yeah a minute ago and how many steps
there are you know if you look at it the
rows are are the things that they have
the steps of their plan the first one
is all related to the country club the
second one is all related to um the
kettleman's and there's like a bunch
more spots that they already have
thought out on that board you were
mentioning about you know you were
talking about like you know what their
plan was and and how that
how they're expecting um
howard to respond and and that's the
thing that that caught me on the on the
rewatch was that there are they really
it's an elaborate plan it's not
something that
is just a few steps in out kind of thing
yeah and if you try to figure out what
are they doing with howard's car
um you know the way the board is set up
basically the top post-it note seems to
be like that is the step of the plan and
the posted notes beneath it are kind of
the details so step one the first
post-it note that's now crossed out was
a little baggy of drugs and underneath
that you saw the country club so step
two i think it says kettles as kind of
hard to make out yeah so i think code
for kettleman's and underneath that you
see the carrot you see an angry face
which i assume is the stick so
what are they doing to howard's car
step three the image they have looks
like a woman's heel
their shoe
so i wasn't sure how to interpret that
you know the only thing that comes to
mind is they uh you know put a heel a
shoe in uh howard's car
and cliff mains like that's my wife's
shoe you're having an affair with my
wife
you know or uh you know you think of the
prostitutes that showed up at uh jimmy's
law at um howard's lunch with cliff but
uh just food for thought also i just
want to throw this out there in the one
percent chance that i i'm right which is
it
it also kind of reminded me of like
cinderella and like the glass shoe so if
if there's something that turns out to
be like just the right fit
i called it the metaphorical shoe yeah
okay yeah i already know what's going to
happen so i can't really
[Laughter]
not not completely but i i saw
ray was on
jimmy kimmel
and they showed an extended clip of
of the next episode and
it gives away a little bit of it in that
it's a miracle that i haven't seen any
spoilers at this point
well i did a video about the about the
teaser and and you know i i was working
on all day so i hadn't seen it and i
mentioned that this thing might happen
when i was talking about it and i got a
bunch of comments right away that said
oh that's confirmed that's happening for
sure
and i looked up the clip it's just you
know it's just it's it's the shot of
them when they're in
you know their it's
kim and jimmy at home they're talking
about it and and she just gives out a
detail from the plan and okay
confirm something
steve mueller thank you for the 499
again it says the real question is
the real question is does anyone other
than mike find out that lalo is still
alive
you know it's funny that when you think
about it in that
where they're at right there you know
gus suspects that that um
that lala was still alive
hector is the only one that knows for
sure that he's still alive right
yeah
yeah
and i thought it was i said it so
definitively
well gus believes it but he doesn't have
proof he just has a feeling about it
hector's the only one that actually
talked to him and knows for sure
and i thought that was a nice i thought
that was a pretty nice touch that you
know whenever whenever nacho's saying
that stuff he does believe that not you
know not that not that lala's dead
and it might and it might open the door
a little bit to that idea that that jim
was saying earlier about how they're not
above
you know kind of destroying this perfect
ending that he had he thinks that lola's
dead so that may that may have given him
some of that um
you know confidence to to to go toward
you know to go after hector that way
when in reality you know lalo's still
out there he could he could pretty
easily just slip across the border and
kill manuel without without too much
trouble
but you know nacho never knew that so it
wasn't something that would have been on
his mind
but yeah i i don't know if anyone else
is going to find out if he's alive
because
um
you know i don't know how he's going to
play how
i mean obviously i i have my thoughts
about what he's doing right now
it's not it's not albuquerque related
but the you know their worlds are all
going to
um
collide again
and and in the end you know it
there it has there are some consequences
or you know implications if people know
the truth about what happened
i think i guess what's most important is
that nacho did kind of protect gus from
from you know being involved i don't
think people are going to find out i
don't i don't think they're going to
find out that gus was really involved
the solomonkos will always
assume he was anyway so it doesn't
really change anything
but you know other people will could
definitely find out that he's still
alive
you know jimmy and kim
you know
for sure
a little uh thank you joseph sheldon for
the 199.
do you even think balsa believes gus
believes gus's story
i assume you're talking about the story
of
alvarez
um
what do you guys think i i i kind of
think balsa is
it doesn't really matter in a way like
as long as there's as long as they're
making money and and
they're not killing each other then then
he's pretty he's pretty neutral on on
whether it's true or not
yeah i think back to uh some of my time
in corporate america in business
meetings where people are trying to
figure something out and you'll see
managers that just they just want to get
to an answer that allows them to move on
and forget about it so sometimes you
hear an explanation you're like i don't
know if that quite fits but good enough
okay let's just move on from this and i
get similar vibes from juan balsa where
he's just like it fits all right can we
move forward
so he might tell himself he believes it
even if he doesn't quit
because that is his only motivation
right is to is to appease elattio and
bring him what he wants and what he
wants is money i mean that
you know the little thing of him with
the frunk and uh just thinking that
you know like that that's that pretty
much he's that
like paul
eladio is a strange character isn't he
because he's he's like the most feared
person but he's kind of just like uh
i don't know what the word is you know
just
i mean he's he's kind of soft
he's very sensual
yeah
that's a good way to describe it but i
mean he's just he's not terrifying other
than his
yeah
but yeah i agree he doesn't he's not
scary uh
he you know he he likes to party he
likes to hang out and chill he likes to
find things in life
and yet in the end he's like on top of
this ruthless empire
yeah someone in the comments just said
he's a man child and you know i
that's i there i know there's a good
there's a better word a better
descriptor out there but i i can't think
it's just
uh you know he just seems like he's he
he doesn't it's hard to imagine that he
worked hard
and and did the things that the people
he has under him that he's expecting
them to do it's hard to imagine he seems
disconnected from it all doesn't he
like he just sits there and he just he
enjoys the watching them
fight with each other and and compete to
give him
give him more yeah you know i do think
he's he's a little scary in his
casualness when he's discussing um
important matters like
when when we see the flashback to gus
and max meeting with him when he
essentially gets to the part of the
conversation where he's saying well why
do i need you gus i can just kill you
and max can cook for me and then when he
gets to the part where he starts
insinuating that they were sort of
handing out drugs in his territory
without his permission and the subtext
is you guys did something pretty bad
here and might not walk away with your
lives but he says it with the same
casualness with which he says everything
else
and that comes off as kind of uh as
pretty terrifying
uh um is this is this yeah boy is that
is this one of your brothers
i don't know maybe they're all upstairs
which one of you is your boy yeah
thank you for the two dollars uh he
they're asking that question again if uh
the real question which is are you
brothers slash related they might answer
that in the finale of uh
the better call saul so
just have to keep watching
yeah
um
here we have another question about we
we covered this last week but i guess we
can we can talk about it again jim i
listened to your podcast and i know that
uh not this episode three but the for
the last one and i know that this was
something that you and alexis were
talking about too i know gus wanted
nacho dead but wouldn't there be a
chance that nacho would rat out gus if
the salamancas had caught him at the
motel
acatillo um
so yeah this was a huge question
why did he do this and
we kind of went through that i i did a
video where i i
put it together the best i could
and it you know it kind of boils down to
the fact that
gus set it up it's not a great plan you
know he gives them a gun he has tyrus
tell him the the specific instruction
that if anyone comes through the door
shoot
so you know
and then he sends balsa and his men
to the location hoping that that's
what's going to happen he wants nacho to
die
in a shootout specifically
and people have a hard time accepting
that that's what he was doing because
it's not a great plan you know like
we're used to seeing gus have everything
under control and there's a significant
problem that could that could arise in
this situation
so yeah like um
the answer to the question is yes there
there was a very
i think nacho i mean i like nacho he's a
great character but i think he would rat
in a heartbeat if if
you know if he was under
under serious uh you know like tuko
maybe not i mean we think we we talked
about this last time maybe tuko he might
not break under the pressure but nacho
is definitely
he he's not even family you know what i
mean
he's worried about his dad if they were
cutting into him and and you know
i think he would definitely ride out gus
what do you guys think
no yeah i think his overriding
motivation was protect my father
uh i think he'll do whatever it takes to
make that happen i don't think he has
any loyalty whatsoever to gus
uh he's just playing the cards he's
dealt and trying to do it's all it's all
survival soul survivor instinct you know
i think that's why he's trying so hard
to get a hold of mike as well right it's
not just to get him out of the situation
he's in but to make sure
that
he's going to protect his father um and
yeah and he probably does rat gus out if
you know hector and then the cousins are
torturing him
because i think he knows that with mike
sort of having at least a little bit of
control over there on gus's side that
his father is less likely to die from
mike
than he is from hector or sorry less
likely to die from gus than he is from
hector
yeah
and um
i think we're gonna have to probably
start to think about wrapping this up
um
i
i'll look through here and see if i can
find something else um anybody anybody
any last-minute thoughts that you want
to throw out there before we
wrap it up
uh one quick observation that i was
kicking myself because i didn't bring it
up on our podcast earlier in the week
because i figured i'll just mention it
here but uh in all the jimmy and kim
scenes i feel like we're seeing them be
a couple more than we have before the
way they're like helping each other get
dressed the way uh you know jimmy offers
up his suit in the first episode or a
sports jacket for kim to give to her
client and so i think it's no mistake
that when they're working together on
this scheme
is when at least on the outside they
appear as a couple more than we like a
traditional couple more than we've ever
seen them before
yeah when i was cutting my video
yesterday i i noticed that i noticed
that um
just how intimate and how how natural it
looked whenever they were
were getting ready looking at the board
together and that was a key part of it
right there they're so relaxed they're
so in the in the in just being a couple
because they're looking at the board and
thinking about their next steps in their
in their plan
yeah i mean i said this on our podcast i
feel like
jimmy has found his dream partner right
uh
he he had a marco back in the day but
like
you know marco can only fulfill so many
of his needs
so
like the fact that they're scamming
together probably does bring them much
closer
yeah and i i think i i don't know if it
was in this in the stream last week when
i brought it up or if it was in my video
but yeah that was that's the thing that
started hitting me
making jimmy so much more tragic in
relation to that you know that golden
mansion is that he really does have
exactly what he would want right now i
mean of course he's damaged you know
he's walking walking wounded at the
moment but
he has the perfect ideal
partner
at least he thinks he does you know
and then the whole idea of her not being
there it just makes it
all that much worse
yeah although i like i think kim is
jimmy's ideal partner it's not obvious
to me that jimmy is kim's ideal partner
i don't i don't have an alternative to
propose but it doesn't give me that same
feeling of of that fit
or um they in some ways are bringing out
the worst in each other so what's the
opposite of ideal
the uh
the worst the worst partners
um
what's that what's the literal word for
the opposite of ideal
non-ideal
clearly sort of like a
maladaptive yeah we're getting we're
getting towards the end whenever we
can't think of of regular uh vocabulary
words um
yeah i i think i i don't know i think
that's one of the things that's really
exciting about where we're at right now
too is that we we don't know that much
about kim you know we kind of touched on
that earlier
we don't we don't have nearly as much
information to go off of when we think
about
what she would actually want you know
like we know that she worked her way up
yeah you know we know that she she came
from nothing i think we can we can
we can kind of take her at her her word
on all that stuff and that
she picked this you know she got she got
in the in the mail room
she she worked hard she got her degree
and she became a very good lawyer
and
something happened in that process where
she realized that that there was it
wasn't enough like it wasn't
it wasn't satisfying and
you know
the question is is there something
underneath the surface that is is the is
the reason that that's the that that's
the way or
you know i mean
jimmy's not very good at
he's not very good at he's very good at
conning people of gaining their
confidence and getting over on them but
he's not very good at being something
that he's not you know i mean like
i think we had we got a really good
indication of that when he went to davis
and maine and worked for that period of
time
you know essentially she was doing the
same thing maybe you know she was just
there
doing what she had to do to get to come
up and you know i think it's pretty
fascinating that we really don't know
what what's underneath that you know and
i can't wait to find out and steve rich
this is kind of a few minutes ago now
but thank you for the 499 he says
definitely agree even how they shared
that cigarette and
yeah like i think we're talking about
that same scene there where
they just they look so they look they
look so natural in a way that they never
never have before
we got another one here
um
nava down south 20 thank you nacho
ending was great but left a bad taste in
my mouth if i was the father i wouldn't
be oblivious of nacho situation
and if it was myself or son
would it would have obliterated the
cartel from mike's point of view
love it thanks
yeah i think it's one of the things that
that
is fascinating about the
nacho character i i was just writing
something about that before as uh before
we started out uh the
the way that you know and i and i
touched on it earlier but just the way
that he
that his father doesn't know because he
he doesn't allow him to know you know
that he keeps him from that and
he they don't run away together because
he doesn't cross that line and say look
we're going to die if you don't do this
you know i get it i get it you're proud
and you don't want to you know you don't
want to take this this thing that i set
up where your
your business is is bought and paid for
you get a good price and then we just
walk away i get it but dad they're going
to kill you they're going to kill us you
know what i mean i'm i hate to put this
on you but i have to because we have to
get out of town
and now's the time he never does that
instead he turns the other way and he
says
i'm going to figure this out because i
don't want to i don't want to burden my
father with that you know that that's
kind of a classic dad move is is like
the stubbornness
like that i think that resonates with us
a little bit
[Laughter]
yeah and and like i said if he if he i
think if you give manuel the the full
information of what's there or what's
really happening
maybe he reacts different
but you know if you think if you look
back at the way that the their you know
that all played out
nacho was pretty pretty particular to
make sure that he didn't let that
sink in you know
he could have he could have like i said
he could have just said look we got to
get out of here
i get it you don't want to do it but
this is you know time to pull
pull up your big boy pants or whatever
you know what i mean like we gotta roll
yeah it does seem like his father
doesn't see the full gravity of the
situation and the relationship seems to
be
nacho my son he keeps making these
mistakes but they're his mistakes and
they're his choices
what more can i do but tell him here is
the path you should take
i can't force you to do it and so for
his father this is just the same thing
he's been going through for years
you know maybe he hears something's a
little different in nacho's voice but
even that might just be okay nacho's
hitting a sort of rock bottom which
maybe he has to do in order to get
better
uh yeah if he truly understood the
gravity of the situation even then
though he probably would have made the
wrong choice he would have gone to the
police
which would have likely gotten them both
killed
it's frustrating to watch but i think
that's just part of the mess of emotions
that we're going to feel watching this
play out
yeah
yeah i i there there might be something
to that if he didn't if he did you know
he he might have not let him know about
what was going on because there is an
inherent risk in him going to the police
that that's his answer for everything is
to
it's sort of um
i i can't remember where i heard it but
i i heard someone mention
you know for someone who is
i mean you get the idea that that
nacho's father is a first generation
immigrant you know which i i think of my
grandfather in that situation you know
like
um
they had they had a different they had a
different um
relationship with
culture and with government and
everything you know i mean they have an
investment in thinking that
the police will keep you safe and that
you know if you just do the right thing
and you you put your head down and you
work hard
it'll pay off you know what i mean
whereas uh you know
his son is his son
got sucked into this life and and the
reality is much different
and then you know he would he would be
able to you know
really appreciate from his his point of
view in this you know what i mean
[Music]
all right so if you guys have any final
questions now is the time um because i
can feel
i can feel us all
starting to
to hit that low point um
we're in that little puddle of oil right
now
we're all cut we're all covered in that
sludge yeah just thinking about that it
is
what a terrible thing to have happen to
you we um last season you know to
celebrate the end of the season we did a
sort of saw cast uh feat of strength
competition
where we figured out how much seven
million dollars would weigh it's about
150 pounds and we filled a big duffel
bag and we had a race to see who could
run the fastest with that duffel bag so
i think this season it's going to be we
need to submerge ourselves in a tank of
oil who can hold their breath the
longest yeah so this is going to be an
intense uh who's going to which of us is
around during the breaking bad timeline
which of us is going to come out of that
oil tank which will just never emerge
yeah
that's one of those things you just have
to accept that they took a little
liberty with right i mean jimmy couldn't
have physically carried seven million
dollars
through this no it's doable and we did
it yeah we can attest we even had a we
even had a little a little uh bottle to
simulate davis and main on you know
yeah no it's tough but i did get kind of
bruised up from all the weights that
were in there yeah so it's definitely
tough but my my takeaway is that it's
it's doable it would it would push you
to the brink of death yeah much like it
did us
yeah i mean
you know i i just i just assume that
they that you know it was close so they
thought you know it would be great for
for the dramatic effect but
i i was under the impression that it
would be impossible so i'm glad that you
guys are doing doing that work out there
and
getting the answers to questions that
you know i didn't really i didn't
realize i had
you know it's like the mythbusters we're
the meth busters
[Laughter]
so yeah i'm sure as soon as we end this
i'm gonna think of a hundred things that
i wanted to
say uh
before i started but you know all things
come to an end
all men must die nacho found that out
for sure
um
there's good ends and there's bad ends
we got mina in the chat who's who's been
asking this question a lot here and i'll
just pull it up for a second uh wanna
know if mike could have killed everyone
and rescued nacho you know i had that
same thought in the moment when
when mike said do it the moment nacho
pointed the gun at bulsa's head it's
like
well
okay logically let's play it out what
happens if nacho blows
bolsa's brains out
uh all hell breaks loose it's total
chaos mike is
in a good spot there he could probably
take out i don't know at least like two
or three of them i like to believe i
think he has no if he's like all right
i'm committed to like the try to save
nacho somehow situation or at least
uh
like in the moment just an act of
justice from like from god from far away
here uh i like to believe he could kill
everyone in that moment but
realistically i don't think it's
possible as much as mike's urge in that
situation be like yeah like i be all
these people should burn
well
let's say he takes everybody out right
yeah he's not going to take out gus
right he's going to leave gus alive um
so this will be the second miraculous
survival by nacho and also a miraculous
survival by gus what does a lodio think
of that
no it's not good yeah
it's sort of it reminds me of like every
time jesse has some kind of hair brained
idea or reactive idea and
walter's like okay then what what's what
specifically do you do after that and
and you realize it all falls apart and
unless you think through things very
carefully you're just making things
worse claudio's gonna be like all right
uh
so nacho your dad's dead um mike your
granddaughter's dead you know there's
going to be retribution i think
yeah yeah i i i don't know you know i
mean he he was
the the thing about mike is we're not
100
sure
you know on on his background but it's
clear that he was in
he was a sniper in in vietnam right that
that that's alluded to at least whenever
he's talking to the gun dealer right um
yeah so he's trained and he probably
could have killed a lot if not all of
them they can't do anything to him from
that distance
not immediately right they can just run
for cover
yeah they can just run for cover so
technically he may have been able to
take out a lot of them if not all of
them or whatever but you know what you
said there is is is the is the reality
of the situation
it doesn't matter
that's why gus lets him be up there in
the first place because he knows it
doesn't matter
on some level that you know
the the those guys are all replaceable
it's a business it's a machine
they they they have personalities and we
know them and they do things and
everything else but someone will take
their place
and eladio you know he'll he'll
he'll make sure that there's
consequences for killing his guys you
know
i think that's that's very um
you know it makes it really fascinating
because you know in the moment you have
those emotions going and everything else
is going on but the reality is is fixed
you know that's what that's why he had
to die that day you know there's that's
why nobody could really change that
because that's the life he chose
and that's the way things played out
and at least he got to do it on his own
terms and at least he you know at least
he got a guy like mike
to
say that he would at least try to
protect his father because that's really
the best that he could have and then he
got to deliver an awesome line about
sucking down jello to hector yeah
after telling him hey you know what you
know how you can't walk anymore or
really think or do anything
[Laughter]
that was me that was me i did that
i'd do it again
i would have killed your you know i
would have killed your nephew myself if
i if i could have you know
it's a pretty good end and i think that
should be ours i want to thank everybody
from coming out i will give you guys all
a chance to to plug a little bit before
we go start with you gil go ahead and
give out your any info you want about to
my viewers here
sure um if you head over to our youtube
channel one take you can just search
o-n-e-t-a-k-e you'll see videos covering
tv movies a bunch of videos about better
call saul in the week leading up to the
new season i did saw week and released a
new kind of video essay every day
focusing on a different character a
different aspect of the show and if you
just want to hear us me and adam plus a
couple of other brothers sometimes talk
more about better call saul you can
search sawcast on any podcast app and
you can find us there too
okay
adam you have anything to add to that
no he took the words right out of my
mouth
all right and then jim what do you got
what do you got to plug over there
uh we do the better cast saw podcast uh
my wife and i alexis uh every week on
wednesdays uh after the episode comes
out
so uh yeah just
search apple podcast spotify wherever
you listen to podcasts
and you'll find us
there yeah and i'll provide links um in
the in the description of this video
where you can find these guys these are
people i talk to regularly about
stuff you know not just better calls all
different shows and different things
that are going on um jim
you know your podcast i listen to
you know different you guys do all kinds
of different shows so i listen to your
to your stuff quite a bit and
you have actually the whole entire you
started with season one on better calls
didn't you
oh yeah we started back in season
three no season four of breaking bad
yeah so there's a big
there's a big old uh a big long catalog
of of content there that you can there's
a rabbit hole that you can go down if
you want to um
i think um yeah so i'll just have com of
links in there i do want to thank you
all for coming out um
we're not really sure if there's going
to be more of these in the near future i
think there's a good possibility that
when we hit a point like this something
that happened this week with nacho
we'll be doing more
i'll let you know you can follow me on
twitter or you know i'll try to do a
community post or something like that to
keep you guys
up to date on what the plans are for
that
um
you know where to find me this is my
channel right here
and i just uh thanks everybody for
coming out i'll talk to you soon
yeah thanks for having us thanks
everyone thanks pete